you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body image not a
big home improvement
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animal
you're a strange animal
you're getting louder with crowder
[Music]
that sound means it's the sound of the
week and glad to be with you i am your
host stephen crowder producing with me
in video studio as always is jared who
is not gay you can follow him on twitter
at not gay jared i fulfill my label
obligations and draw your own
conclusions we good we're good not gay
and not dead no not dead not dead
the rumors are false now that i hear
myself on mike i can hear the the the
the
sinus
is just kind of hanging in there
it started last thursday remember we had
uh with that one longer break and i was
going what what is with i feel f i feel
funny
and um little known fact one can
contract sinus aids speaking of
diseases
fight for 15 is trending everywhere by
the way great guests we have julie
barofsky formerly token libertarian
chicon we have super mexican of the
rightscoop.com wonderful site
we have ed morrissey with his new book
talking about that he knows a lot about
the the politics the micro politics how
the delegates work how the counties work
but we actually have and by we i mean
not gay jared
have an exclusive scoop this week it's
trending everywhere fight for 15. all
the bernie voters these people they want
15 minimum which specifically fast food
workers yes
so
let me lay the foundation and jared as
you speak we can uh you know i'll bring
up these screenshots um it's entirely
fake people are talking about whether
the idea is good or not it's a scam
and
uh uh well jared do you want you want to
start off with what what we did because
we were going to send jean guitar
noted bernie fan bernithan he was all
about it to the fight he was really
excited to go too which was kind of
right disheartening yes
so um
and i have this up so i i
not gay jared produces these things and
i said now kj we need to set this up
find out where these for 15 are going
and i have this up here on my screen
where you can see so not gay jared what
did you do so we signed up for the email
because we thought hey that's the best
way to stay in contact yep we thought
hey we want us to be involved we want to
be there support the great cause
let's find out where it's going to
happen and when it's for jean geek so we
can inform him so send him in and you
signed up with emails with emails to
make sure we were secure
um no affiliation with ladder with
crowder so it wouldn't be
scratched nope so you have the screen
and they were saying this is where you
this is where you sign up to be a part
of the protest i have screenshot one
here let me bring up another one uh
another screenshot biggest ever global
strikes and protests someone saying help
us grow the fight share now these
screenshots i have here so these were
all being sent directly to your inbox
correct yes okay lots of personal
letters from mcdonald's employees about
doing it for their son we're glad to
have you along
doing the right thing let's pull
together well here it says today we are
striving for in over 300 cities share
you know stand strong share this now we
have emails here too they were supposed
to tell you
where these were taking place and then
eventually said give us your phone
number and we'll text you
so you and i were thinking this might be
like a flash mob scenario right yeah
where's gather everyone together right
last minute
bomb the media because you signed up for
the email list you gave them your phone
number building hype for weeks building
hype for weeks and i have the text right
here saying stay tuned your message is
on the way
work with us share this
did they ever tell you
where the protest would take not once
not once and i couldn't find out
no i called half a dozen mcdonald's
specifically because they were targeting
mcdonald's and fast food places not one
employee
not a single employee nor manager had
heard of it this happened to me last
time the this happened i went to a
couple fast food places in person right
they hadn't even heard of it they didn't
even know what i was talking about no um
and if you look at the picture so they
trend it's all out seiu members pictures
of them they went at 6 45 a.m and said
you know brothers and sisters we'll be
back later today later tonight what why
are you protesting at 6 45 a.m photos
and then they're gone and they're back
later
but i mean we unless we're missing
something we signed up for the email
lists we made the phone calls not gay
gear had tried proactively to find out
where these protests are
and no no answer we checked all over
michigan all over detroit uh chicago
chicago
they claim their big claim is 300 cities
they've gotten on board with this right
300 cities
and the text to me said maybe this is
just you know i'm reading too much into
it but join the thousands yes thousands
so do the math
let's be really aggressive let's say 10
000 people which if there was 10 000
people they probably said tens of
thousands of people right right
do the math 300 cities
10 000 people at the most that's 33
people per city that's not much of a
movement well and the thing is they're
counting you they're counting me this is
what's so dishonest they're counting i
wasn't there not gay jared's email as
one of the millions or tens of thousands
representing whatever representing
standing strong so they tell you this is
important for you to know
everyone out there you want to talk
about astro turf these are paid union
protesters most of whom do not work at
these fast food establishments
and they are claiming among their ranks
we are supported by thousands no they're
paying protesters professional
protesters to show up unions do this and
they are including someone like not gay
jared who they deliberately misled
into signing up that he could be a part
of their protest and it was a shutout
they do not want anyone to be a part of
this now contrast this with the tea
party with the march on washington that
happened with with glenn beck at one
point or the same thing with with jon
stewart when he did the counter protest
in washington or even occupy wall street
right if you're creating a genuine
protest the whole goal is to get as many
people as possible to be a part of a
movement
and they did the exact opposite of this
and i don't know if anyone else has done
this i don't know why no one is talking
about this we have all of the emails we
have all the texts if anyone wants to
question us on it we can prove it and
remember we we planned our week around
this to send you out we did we did we've
been pulling 16 hour days and a big
video coming out by the way when people
ask why are you always running the
school of rock schoolhouse rock
foreshadowing
dummies
and we planned our week around this and
nowhere were we able to get this
information no and the only pictures you
see are seiu members and union members
who of course do not work at mcdonald's
i couldn't even prove it but there was
one email there you'll see it has like
all the different cities sharing their
photos
and i couldn't prove it but i would bet
i would bet you can find a lot of those
photos already online
from past rallies from past rallies i
couldn't prove it because i didn't have
enough time today right but i would be
it would be an interesting uh venture in
journalism there well you know here's
the crazy thing we're not journal i'm
not a journalist this is an
entertainment based program
right and we just wanted to screw with
people we just wanted to screw with
people and then every now and then we
stumble across these
and we realize nobody else is doing the
work
nobody cena's not doing the work fox
news isn't doing the work hello
none of these other news sources are
doing work help us think about they
don't want to create any they don't want
to get to the bottom of this this is
really basic stuff this is an entirely
fraudulent movement it's a giant scam i
think i said they think that if they
could just create enough hype
in the social media sphere creative hype
on twitter eventually it'll come to
fruition or existing reality i don't
know if they just keep telling people
this is a big movement a lot of things
are happening people are excited people
people are marching the streets
eventually
i don't know but why wouldn't they want
me to show up to something
that's why they don't well they don't
want you to show up because they want to
control it they want to put on a front
and they know that many workers don't
really want to join their union ranks
they a lot of workers understand
automation a lot of workers see what's
happened in places like california a lot
of them know if they didn't show up this
morning
they'd be fired well yeah but that's
what the unions are gonna say soon that
shouldn't happen you should never be
fired for protesting and leaving your
your job what about the fact that you
cannot get correctly
at kfc
white meat and dark meat it's never
happened no
original extra crispy they never get it
right visually see the difference they
can never get it right you imagine these
kind of people like ending up in the
military protesting like oh we didn't
get our uh our rations today just right
we're striking tomorrow right the whole
world would go to
hell
you know what's so funny two people on
twitter were talking about this or going
you know what you could easily pay for
this if you just gave the ceo pay to the
employees like they just think that the
ceo
you swipe a card and they've like they
don't understand the second biggest
number on any expenditure list for for a
business is employee costs yeah it's a
mcdonald's worth six point with 61
billion okay how many people do they
employ
and this is what's so crazy you just
tell someone they deserve something you
stir them up with a hashtag and they
don't they don't even pay attention to
the lie but remember if you just raise
the price of the big mac by 15 and a
half cents you could pay for it all it's
a no-brainer the big mac isn't worth 15
and a half cents to begin with with such
bad math on their part and whatever the
numbers are thrown out there well you
know 15 why not make it 19.
why not make it 25 why not at that point
you just pick a number and say you know
we had people tweeting us this is a good
example tweeting us saying well you know
what you try and live on that kind of a
of a wage we can't even eat
okay on days that i don't eat out now
listen we do we do pretty well i'm not
gonna lie about that
we've been pretty blessed we've had some
hardships neither of us are in a food
line
and i'm grateful and i'm not going to
lie about it you know what i've been
able to hire jared i've been able to
hire brilliant people like courtney and
casey and and hopefully more and we want
to grow and we don't do any unpaid
interns um but yeah
we're not we're not struggling i
understand that people have it far worse
off than we do right now and i'm
grateful but you know what if i'm not
eating out and i do eat out quite a bit
if i'm not
it's under eight dollars a day i've done
the math people say you know poor people
don't have access to healthy food milk
eggs fruit veggies meat
all of the latter which you can buy on
sale
you can eat like a professional athlete
this is where you insert your [ __ ] it's
not that complicated
what my [ __ ] chain chain [ __ ] oh
jank jake jank from young turks young
turks folks people it's not that
complicated okay
i like the rationale i'd like to reason
by arguing but instead i'll just say
come on
mainstream media what
that's a perfect young turks impression
if you question it i'm going to have you
jailed like bill nye wants to do with
actual scientists we'll talk about that
afterwards i want to talk more about
this fight for 15 and this populist bull
crap and this idea that the poor have it
so horrible in the united states i was
raised in quebec the poor have it worse
stay tuned
[Music]
in fact it was a little bit frightening
but they fought
[Music]
this is so great that we're all joined
together and we're fighting for the
workers rights yeah man that's cool i
want to be paid more too yeah the
minimum wage is [ __ ] we deserve at
least 15 hours yeah man i'll tell you
what i could really use like 19 now yeah
19 is better than 15.
you print out all these flyers with 15
on it
but that's [ __ ] we need 19 yeah
fight for 19.
fight for 19 and new posters
[Applause]
[Applause]
glad to be back and you know we were
going to move on so bill nye wants to
jail bill nye a non-scientist noted not
a scientist but he taught me how to make
some excellent rock candy wait really
yeah that was it
crystal meth
well that's what we called it
that's that's what happened not gay
jared uh watched bill nye one day and
his mom said what's going on i smoke
rocks
you sound like dave chappelle for some
reason that's how it happened
and she said
she said what's wrong with you he said
[ __ ] build that
all right so we were talking about the
fight 15
before this so we were talking about
let's talk about this okay
uh food you know we've done this math a
lot by the way not gay jared gate was
very very nice and gave this money to a
homeless man when we were downtown and
coach mark ripito was visiting
and as we're walking up because you know
i'm hobbled jared is giving him did we
tell the story on air i don't think i
don't think
you always forget there's so much that
happens in a week
there's an argument to go daily with
something like this but um
we're downtown so we're pulling up and
we just see you know jared's little
dainty hand coming out with a cup and
some change hey hey just sit there
straight my hand is way bigger than
yours your hand's not bigger than mine
oh yeah proportionally yes but fingers
what do you mean length length all right
um does not correlate with grip strength
well you're not left-handed i'm not okay
so the right hand but the point is we
see a hand going out with change
and we're rocking up i i just hear mark
he's going oh
no he knows what's going to happen the
guy takes the money from jared thank you
captain thank you captain god bless you
captain
and we're walking up and as we're
walking up and jared is passing him
money out of the window so we're trying
to get in the car
he stops us to shake us down he's just
gotten money from you he knows we're in
the same car
substantial amount of change it looked
like a full cup and he turns to hey
captain do you have any and i said you
know listen i don't he's the one who
would have any change it was in the
console oh yeah but you don't you don't
you can't find anything you can't spare
anything and then tell you give away
your change of the console
well i figured it out afterward by the
way it's been taken from your pay so it
all works out in the end that's why you
don't fight for 15.
and he turns to mark and before he can
even get to speaking with coach mark he
looks at him
and he just says
go away
he says it without telling whiskey cool
whip the kind of the kind they kind of
rattled the whole car a little bit
because of the joke
away
and the guy just stopped and left
but my point is and we people have
averaged what folks make we've seen him
a couple times since then yes we've seen
many times since then people panhandling
often make more than minimum wage people
don't know that um
for a lot of people it's a scam doesn't
mean you shouldn't help people who are
down in their luck but that's just
reality
okay if you're making let's say minimum
wage what's minimum about eight seven
dollars an hour yeah something eight
seven forty maybe the point is you can
live off of that very very easily it
comes down to choice we were talking
about this because you were eating some
kind of sweet and sour skittles
yeah it was just clever it was sweet and
sour it was sweet and i got out no you
got it i was worth i went for both as
far as skittles go
you should still feel great shame but
you got your money's worth now for that
same price you could have had
two bananas a pint of milk and probably
i don't know something else i don't know
raspberries a couple of eggs think about
it you get a gallon of milk it's what
399 bananas are 99 cents you get a whole
handful of them
this idea that you know you say that now
if i can go back
no i'd probably get the skills again
because there's been there i think
they're banana flavor skittles so yeah
we're good that's what i figured i'm
resolved the point here this is this
fight for 15 you have a bunch of people
where it's always a problem that's not
themselves
and conservatives have you know there's
this idea compassionate conservatism
people want to ease their guilt no
listen it's okay the problem is you
the problem is you if you look at people
who are successful if you look at people
who have made it beyond minimum wage
jobs in every case some of them do it in
weeks some of them do it months some of
them do it in years
they said i'm going to do what it takes
to get beyond this period there is a
common thread 100 of the time
okay
and generally speaking there's that same
common thread for people who remain in
those employment positions long term
long term some people are down in their
luck absolutely now if they are in that
position long term and they're not
disabled
or particularly maybe not highly
functioning we work with special needs
my wife and i work with special needs
people if you've seen the video on
friendship club a lot of these people
have jobs and they pay them less than
minimum wage they're finding something
for these people to do these people just
want to go out and do something
and some of them actually do work at
mcdonald's we know a guy named dominic
with pretty severe downtime
yeah
this guy calls me great grandpa because
of the gray hairs and sideburns he's
he's a smart ass down syndrome yeah he
is very funny but he's actually moved up
he's like a shift manager at mcdonald's
come on
i'm not trying to say that if if if
dominic with down syndrome can do it you
have no excuse but if dominic with down
syndrome can become a manager at
mcdonald's you probably have no excuse
that's the reality and people get so mad
they talk about corporations let's just
not lose sight of something okay people
talk about socialism in a safety net i
was raised in canada everything costs
more by the way no one believed me when
i said you can get beef high quality
steak for 4.99 a pound in the states
where can you get that
watch them go on sale that's my my
parents do well you know what my mom
does she finds steak when it's on sale
4.99 a pound she puts it in a freezer
bag doesn't even pay for the the freezer
machine sealant whatever you call it
that was a fancy thing she sucks out the
air with a straw
steak dinner
you can get chicken for under two
dollars a pound pork eggs it's very very
easy to do you just have to make the
decision but people so in the states
anyways a lot of people didn't believe
me when i when i threw out these prices
on twitter and i remember thinking i get
that's true in canada we ate these kinds
of foods far less often
let's not lose sight people will walk
into a rite aid or people will walk into
a mcdonald's or they'll walk into a
local coffee roaster company or local
restaurant and go yeah look at coca-cola
these billionaires brilliant corporate
billionaires rigging the system this is
capitalism and they ignore on that same
street
the dozens or hundreds
of hundred thousand airs or low-level
millionaires
it's not one or the other
capitalism has brought more people
has created more moving class structures
than any other system ever in the
history of the world particularly
america's brand free enterprise
capitalism
so it's easy to [ __ ] about the
billionaire but guess what the person
who has that fountain machine that
you're looking at bitching about the
coca-cola because you're thinking about
some ceo has billions
that allowed that guy to open up a
franchise [ __ ] coffee or whatever it
is big b coffee and he's able to make
good money upper middle class and that's
a lot of people and it's available to
nearly all of you if you're basically
competent
so instead of bitching about what
somebody else has try and take part in
the common thread that connects every
single moderately successful american
improve yourself
you're the loser
and i'm not going to say it's not
compassionate we don't need to apologize
for it
if you never advance
it's you you're the problem
all right we're going to have julie
borowski after this break stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
what his breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm harry matheson in the wake
of controversy regarding ben carson's
recent statements as a surrogate for
donald trump's campaign
we take you live to an exclusive
interview with our underground reporter
jimmy jimmy thank you perry mr carson
having said that you would be never
trump if not for your children you've
been criticized as
not a very loyal surrogate
what do you say to your critics well to
be fair i don't think that's
particularly accurate i
in context explain as to why i would be
never trump and and so i wouldn't be
okay i'm still not quite clear
why is it
what's the context in which you would be
never trump well i don't think he'd make
a very good president i think it's
pretty simple and in what context is
that appropriate for a surrogate
to say listen sometimes that'll give me
a dick
we'll keep you up to date as this
exclusive interview unfolds for breaking
news on water with
[Music]
i ain't got a thing
[Music]
jared is asleep at the switch he'll have
to be promptly fired i'm glad to bring
this next guest on um
i i've watched her for a while we sort
of ran in the youtube circles years ago
and um you know where his token
libertarian chick you can follow her
youtube channel i highly recommend it at
uh julie borowski
b-o-r-o-w-s-k-i
and she just moderated the libertarian
party debate so she's she's moving on up
and uh pretty high profile in
libertarian movement yeah julie julie
thanks for coming uh coming on
thank you for having me on okay so was
that pretty exciting you were there i
mean why what's the libertarian party
debate isn't it sort of settled that
it's going to be gary johnson or are
there still other people vying for it
well there's actually i monitored the
debate and there was about i guess eight
other candidates um there's a couple
front runners gary johnson will be the
the front runner then there's austin
peterson and
others so yeah that was a really good
time did you do you have a favorite
yourself or you stay
doing this
i don't want to endorse anyone yet i
apologize this is my cast that's okay
you can endorse the cat
i think um i probably agree with austin
peterson the most i do know him um gary
johnson i do like however i watched the
fox news debate with him the other night
and he said some couple a couple of
things that i didn't quite agree with
gary johnson
yeah
he said that um baker should be forced
to bake a cake for gay weddings
and he wants to limit um
mentally ill people from getting guns so
that was kind of oh
well on its surface people go what is
she saying here she's saying mentally
ill people should get guns but i know
what she's saying and i actually agree
with what julie is saying so hold your
horses you why are you laughing not gay
jared what is so funny i'm saying there
is nothing funny
what are you laughing about is it
nothing's funny is it the
cat cats are never funny is it because
oh i think i know he's laughing because
you mentioned that about gary johnson
and the cake and i've talked about it
i've always had the sneaking suspicion
that gary johnson might be a little bit
light in the loafers and so the the the
gay cake thing would stand to reason i
have nothing to substantiate that but
sometimes it's a little flip and and and
uh and feminine for a male candidate am
i the only one who's noticed
i i wouldn't go that far but he does
have a quite a few liberal positions no
i'm not well i'm not talking and see you
took it to a whole other level with the
positions i'm not talking about what
you're saying oh i am saying i think he
might be a homosexual uh but i have
nothing to substantiate i just mean
sometimes he goes up there and i'm like
oh i might stand a reason with the cakes
i actually like gary johnson um funny
enough for the for i've talked about
this if it is gary johnson uh donald
trump and hillary clinton there's not
enough of a contrast uh and i i don't
know i might flip the switch for gary
johnson i have no idea um
even though i don't consider myself a
tried and true libertarian i think there
are a lot of people right now you know
what it comes down to i don't believe
that any of them are pro-life
at this point and i'm not a one-issue
voter but that is a closed-handed issue
and i think gary johnson would be the
guy obviously has no chance of winning
if he did
he'd cut the beast off of the head and
even though he's not pro-life he would
defund it so i'm like okay if someone's
not pro-life but they want to end my tax
dollars funding baby killing i can get
on
board i don't know if that stands to
reason
yeah he's pro-choice um austin peterson
is probably i think the
biggest pro-life person in the race uh
donald trump i don't know where he
stands on that issue because he was
pro-life before and now he says you feel
like what day is it and what they asked
about the punishment he didn't even know
so i don't know where he stands on that
issue well exactly same thing it was
austin peterson i just mean a third
party candidate you know it's a protest
vote i understand that but i think we
might if it's donald trump and hillary
clinton i don't think there's enough of
a contrast where i think a protest vote
makes sense
um
at that point and do you do you see a
lot of that in this election people who
never even thought of that you think
coming into the fold just going throwing
their hands up and they're they're tired
of it
yeah definitely i think the libertarian
party i think they're probably going to
do the best that they've done in decades
in this election because it's funny
hillary clinton donald trump it seems
like no one really likes them that much
so i think people aren't going to go for
a protest vote i voted for gary johnson
in 2012 because i didn't like mitt
romney or obama but now i'm definitely
going to vote for a third party because
i can't stand any of the front runners
if it was rand paul would you voted
republican
yeah i would have gone for rainfall okay
so even the next closest thing being ted
cruz why is that a no-go
um
i like ted cruz on some domestic policy
issues but when it comes to foreign
policy he kind of scares me he said
things like let's make the sand glow in
the middle east which is just like for
me i am a non-interventionist so i'm
like oh that's
i don't know i don't know
so i guess my question and i understand
where you're coming from and um
i'm more libertarian than than most
conservatives um i would lean more
libertarian than conservative in a lot
of ways i just don't use a label because
bill maher
fred gutfeld and glenn beck all at one
point i'm like what does the label mean
so i just say conservative and if people
ask me to explain um
what's the libertarian idea right now
how would how do you think a president
should deal for example with isis where
we
are such a hard question and i think
that's why rand paul didn't do as well
this election because of the whole isis
thing um when you talk about
non-interventionism people think you're
a pacifist people think that you're
completely anti-war whereas i think that
most libertarians including myself are
not completely anti-war right i think if
there is a real threat from isis
especially if they're they threaten to
attack us and if they do
i think that
we should respond i'm not completely
like oh let them do whatever they want
to do um but it's definitely a hard
question
do any do you think any liberty because
that's one thing libertarians have just
not had answers for that
and i think more people would look at
them if they did is there anyone there
you think has a solid answer if rand
paul didn't do it would it be peterson
would it be johnson who answers that
question so people go okay
i can take you seriously libertarian
party
oh i i honestly think that's one of our
downfalls right now because people are
so scared of isis all this
fear-mongering
if you don't say you know we're going to
go over and defeat isis people think
that you're weak on that issue
it's one of those really horrible you
just said fear-mongering and i think
that's kind of throwing so then okay so
then you need to kind of rationalize why
is it fear-mongering that would mean
that isis is not a threat so again that
comes back to the question how does a
libertarian candidate say it's
fear-mongering
why
i don't think isis is as big of a threat
as the news makes it out to be okay um
especially to us of course in the middle
east isis is a huge threat to those
people but i don't think they're as big
as a threat to us as the news makes it
out to be but of course when you say
that people just think oh you're just
naive on the issue
yeah i think i think some people would
um
i can understand arguments on that i
mean i can understand certainly looking
back and people saying well okay iraq
didn't work out and that was a mistake
and i can see arguments on both sides
provided they're honest you know
provided they're not spreading
falsehoods like there were no wmds or
something like that if they sailed there
were wmd saddam hut is good but i don't
think we should have done it great i'm
on board with libertarians there
my question is always okay we're here
now you know and and that's the that is
i think an issue like you said is
disconcerting if people aren't offering
a viable solution to deal with it when
when people are sort of being burned
alive in cages i think there are two
libertarians and i think you've just
sort of
which i'm grateful for defined
yourself as there are libertarians who
are going okay good enough is good
enough like you said rand paul you would
have voted for him and i think a lot of
libertarians like the libertarian club
when i was in college you know they're
out of a movement if all of a sudden
right the libertarian candidate actually
has a shot so do you see the libertarian
movement kind of taking like a tea party
approach of taking back the republican
party putting in people like rand or
like justin amash is a great
representative in michigan um do you
think that's that's that's the approach
or do you think go boom full third party
and separate and stay that way
there are different sides to the
libertarian movement i think there are
people who believe in the libertarian
party they're going to go that way and
then there's libertarians who believe
that taking over the republican party is
the right way to go i think a lot of
libertarians just kind of got fed up
with the republican party after ron paul
after what they did to him
and um convention all those rules which
now are backfiring against the
establishment so there's two different
things well i guess there's actually
three different things we also have the
anarchists the movement who want nothing
to do with politics so it's very
interesting yeah those are the people
who if it's not uh if it's not rand paul
they go to bernie the anarchists a lot
of them so i i wouldn't put them in the
same vein as someone who's as thoughtful
as you why is that why did half of ron
paul's people go rand and half of them
go bernie
what is
it doesn't make you couldn't get any
more opposite from ron paul i disagree
with him on some things i love him on
some issues but i don't understand how
someone can rationalize that
am i in the dark here it seems like
there are quite a few people in the
whole ron paul movement which i was a
part of were really just there because
they were contrarians they were
anti-establishment they just wanted to
burn the system to the ground and they
feel that bernie sanders is the best
person to do that but also i've noticed
a lot of ron paul people going to donald
trump
even anarchist who supported ron paul
going to donald trump which makes no
sense to me well how do you like someone
like you who
you know whether someone disagrees with
you or not has been has been consistent
you know see something like the the
alt-right which consisted of a lot of
libertarians and now they're they're
sort of nationalist
trump supporters populism um
what do you think when you're watching
this election unfold and you see people
who claimed your mantle now going trump
oh
i think there are good people who go to
donald trump and they do it for the
right reasons sure but there's also like
you said the alt rights and i've seen
some libertarians go down this rabbit
hole
where they're so against politically
correct culture which i'm against too
sure but they become so completely
against it that they become spiteful
and they go to the alt-right and that
these people those are really insane
people i mean they have legit neo-nazis
in there which is not libertarian
whatsoever no so it's really it's really
scary to see
i i wish we could just bring them back
and just be like okay think about this
be logical like yeah i think it's just
ang a lot of anger and anger's not you
know the right reason to vote um have
you seen because you have someone like
ben shapiro who's conservative but again
much more libertarian than people would
realize if they actually look at what he
believes and you know i've had him on
the show and obviously milo and they've
sort of taken two different directions
and ben's been a target have you felt
some of these people like you just said
some of the not all the alt-right there
are a lot of people who go there for the
right reasons have you felt the wrath of
some of these people for remaining
libertarian and they're not happy with
you
oh yes i get all kinds of hate on
twitter for it
uh
gosh they
say all kinds of terrible things about
me that i'm naive for being a
libertarian still
um i'm politically correct which is
crazy to me that somebody would think
i'm politically correct also that i
don't hate all immigrants so i must you
know be part of this whole politically
correct culture well that's another
thing there are two different kind of
ideas on libertarianism um where
some are
much more open to i guess not
necessarily open but more free borders
um and then there are some who think no
it's a problem we really need to fix and
take seriously
where do you line up and which candidate
i guess because that's a big issue too
like you said the kind of weakness isis
foreign policy for libertarians is not a
good year for them to run immigration is
a hot button issue
how should libertarians handle that in
this election or how do you see it
honestly i i'm torn on immigration
because we do have this huge welfare
state and people come here and some
people just want to get on the
government dole right um some immigrants
do do that do you do that but at the
same time there are some immigrants who
come here who are very smart very
educated and come here for a better life
and they do
contribute to society
um for me i think the biggest issue is
um
how bureaucratic the system is how many
years it takes to become a legal citizen
of this nation i've seen some of my
friends go through that system and for
me that's the biggest issue that people
come here legally and they do they
follow the law they're good people but
it's just so hard to become a citizen
yeah i think i think you're right on
that but my mother being a legal
immigrant would argue that it should be
and no one is more frustrated with
people who don't go through the process
and don't learn the language than a lot
of legal immigrants so
um yeah i think there are two sides to
that coin uh and it's a reasoned
argument speaking of which we must go to
a reasonable break for our evil
corporate overlords hopefully we have
some of that coke brother money but we
will be back dear listener with token
libertarian chick julie borowski stay
tuned
[Music]
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar15.com oh there's another one
you got them thank god for ar15.com they
have ar-15 and accessories for sale and
the best advice there is on the web oh
no there's another one
you got it yeah with your what ar15 from
where yeah
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
[Music]
what's his breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm harry matheson in the wake
of controversy regarding ben carson's
recent statements as a surrogate for
donald trump's campaign
we take you live to an exclusive
interview with our on the ground
reporter jimmy jimmy
dr ben carson i don't think you're fully
aware of
the role of a surrogate you're not
supposed to say these things about
the person you're representing
respectfully no that's not true
and that's the kind of mindset that has
americans tired of politics in general
americans are tired of their surrogates
not trashing the candidates for whom
they work i don't like him
i don't like donald trump
but i have to support him because this
is my job you're the worst surrogate
ever you realize that you're kind of a
dick dude
we'll keep you up to date as this
exclusive interview unfolds for breaking
news a lot with crowder i'm barry
mallison
[Music]
glad to be back serious serious show
serious guest
clever guest smart lady i don't know
that's that's a microaggression right
off the bat damn it not good jared
you're supposed to keep me in line ah
just too much to handle youtube channel
julie barosky b-o-r-o-w-w-s-k-i
i keep wanting to say why uh julie
thanks for being back with us
thanks okay i know i have to go to this
break we have these commercials um yeah
on the immigration issue there are
definitely two sort of splits with with
libertarians um
what about the two-party system
libertarians complain about that a lot
um i'm a big fan of the two-party system
that's why i asked that kind of question
before uh if they think about taking
republican party swaths of the
republican party or staying third party
and you know remaining forever pretty
ineffectual um
what do you think and what's the
sentiment right now in the in the true
libertarian community
like i said there's two camps there um
i'm not against the libertarian party i
vote for the libertarian party a lot of
the times but i think probably taking
over the republican party is a more
effective strategy like you mentioned
justin amash thomas massey ron paul rand
paul all very libertarian leaning who
are in the republican party and they're
doing good
um that i'm not trying to say and people
all always get on me and say oh julie's
trying to tell us what to do i mean you
can do whatever you want to do well
that's the problem with libertarians
especially if you have self-professed
anarchists who then support trump
they're just don't tell me what to do
julie
um
but you know the problem is the
libertarian party right you never win um
i mean the whole reason for the
two-party system i come from i was
raised in canada parliamentary system
right the reason for the two-party
system is to avoid the absolute crap
show that you see right now in a primary
right where someone who can't get above
35 percent of the vote can hijack a
primary and win a nomination well that's
what happens if ever you don't have a a
two-party system right you don't have
someone who represents even close to a
majority and we've had prime ministers
in canada elected with you know i want
to say 35 percent so i think a lot of
libertarians and in college i certainly
wouldn't include you there but a lot of
my libertarian friends like the
two-party system man look at the primary
right now that's what we want to avoid
um
so i i do you think a lot of
do people really think of that or are
they just again angry are libertarians
as angry as the trump and the bernie
voters
i think third parties give people an
alternative like you said it's kind of a
protest vote saying that you know i
don't like any of these two candidates
so i'm going to vote vote for this
person i think it's a good alternative
i'm not exactly opposed to it i think
the problem is that most people are
opposed to third parties because they
don't think they can win so they don't
vote for them right i think that's the
biggest struggle for the libertarian
party is that when you vote for
libertarians
oftentimes people will accuse you of
voting for the democrat in the race um
in 2012 i got accused of voting for
obama i don't know how many times so i
think that's the biggest struggle for
the significant portion of libertarians
did i was shocked to find my friend some
of my friends at reason who voted for
obama shocked at that point no
um and i want you know some of them i
guess they have a they have a
discrepancy as far as what where the
priorities are with social issues and
then of course there's some libertarians
who you know just want to smoke a bunch
of pot um do you do you have to uh to
pat people down at your meetings to make
sure they're not they're not bringing in
the uh
the wacky tobacco
um actually there's a lot of
libertarians who don't smoke pot um yeah
i know but that's what they constantly
talk about
the t-shirts clearly said there would be
pot the t-shirts clearly said yeah i
think
if we just legalized it then we can just
talk about other issues
yeah i don't think libertarians would
you know and that's one thing a good
example is ted cruz or myself
uh okay well here's one people say well
you're not libertarian and pot states
want to legalize pot go ahead
states want to vote and say no
fine
federal government should stay out of it
how is that going to be but
in your states
if
it came up marijuana legalization how
would you vote
what does that have to do again with the
view of a legitimate role of government
two separate things
i was just asking your personal
professional opinion you know
uh well i think we've seen colorado it
hasn't had the results that people
claimed it would um
i i don't know i'd have to think about
it i've never smoked pot i'm i'm open
about that um i don't begrudge people
who do i think generally speaking if
someone's a fully grown adult and
they're healthy
it's probably not that big of a deal
my main issue and this is where you know
again libertarians they should look at
ted cruz as a state issue boom great
instead they focus on him saying i'd
vote against it in my state it doesn't
matter just like it doesn't matter if
you think he's a crazy christian it
doesn't matter if he's the guy who
doesn't want the power that comes with
the job right just like i could vote for
an atheist if he's going i just don't
care i don't want to be enforcing my
beliefs in anyone that's where i think a
lot of libertarians get it wrong with
ted cruz
my issue is people vote it needs to be
honest it's not medicine it doesn't
lower crime kids are not being jailed
for smoking a joint that's not happening
our prisons are not overcrowded with
people who are just single time drug
offenders that's not the case people say
hey we want to vote we want to get high
what we put in our bodies is our own
business and the state says sure i have
no problem with it
yeah i think allstate should legalize it
though
is it okay is that a libertarian
viewpoint for some peop for states to
have the right to say no we saw colorado
we don't want it in texas or i don't
know new hampshire
it's a libertarian position
that's a difficult one because some
libertarians say it should be a state
issue states should decide but also
you have to look it from the
individual's perspective
states can also take away your freedom
um so i think some libertarians will say
that all states should legalize it or
should states have the right to instate
like public schools
oh gosh um
i'm against the federal department of
education right yeah
but i think if the state of michigan
says we want public schools just like
our parents had they should have the
right to do it and if states say we
don't want to the issue yeah so why not
the same with with drugs
because you have to look at it um as an
individual perspective that's how kind
of i view it um
in public schools they're still taking
taxes i'm saying both are the same issue
it's it's not enumerated in the
constitution the powers of the
constitution and i get so much flack for
libertarians i'm going listen if you
don't think i'm an ally
no one is an ally the only ally is
someone who's who's saying smoke weed it
cures cancer in the comments section on
youtube
i think i think yeah states go to it and
you know what you're probably on the
winning side where more states will
legalize it than not
yeah i hope so because i think it's an
individual freedom issue also it's going
to save a lot of taxpayer dollars and as
you said
i think police officers are even coming
around on this issue and saying no we
have better things to do than bust
teenagers for smoking marijuana
um
i certainly think they have better
things to do but can we go we can go can
we do a web extended version there
because i think this is an interesting
topic um
i think there's some interesting uh
information that's come out with
colorado uh but i think we would agree
on most of those things so if you're
listening terrestrially podcast extended
version julie borowski stay tuned
[Music]
it only takes some time
[Music]
[Music]
what's this breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm harry matheson in the wake
of controversy regarding ben carson's
recent statements as a surrogate for
donald trump's campaign
we take you live to an exclusive
interview with our underground reporter
jimmy
jimmy
dr ben carson let's try this
one more time
if you felt this way about donald trump
why would you feel it's your role
to act on his behalf on the campaign
trail listen i think we're in a position
where i don't have a choice
okay i still have some questions about
mr donald trump
okay
didn't she not his first wife
or his second wife
what are his problem how are they gonna
we're just gonna i wanna know
don't you wanna know i wanna know yes dr
ben carson we all want to know
does this mean that you'll no longer be
acting
as a representative of the trump
campaign no i'll certainly still be
representing the donald trump campaign
with great pride and fervor
we'll keep you up to date as this
exclusive interview unfolds for breaking
news on water with crowder i'm barry
mollison
[Music]
[Music]
glad to be back second hour of course
producing with me in studio as always is
jared who is not gay follow him on
twitter at not gay jared i fulfill my
legal obligations draw your own
conclusions we're good we're good follow
me do lots of it not gay stuff there do
lots of it we'll be reading some tweets
from at is jared gaye
afterwards
is jared gaye there are some people you
should follow us on twitter if you're
not is
jared gay at is jared gaye some uh some
sleuths out there some uh some some
hearty boys
you know what i mean they're looking
they're looking into naked jared's path
not funny ha ha funny queer that's what
they're thinking okay before we go
i i want to go into a segment here
uh pretty soon two things not gay jared
i have this up on my screen just got
another text from the fight for 15. so
keep in mind we talked about this in the
first hour at no point
have any of the multiple forms of
contact that not gay jared has given
them
actually been alerted as to where or
when the events take place correct
correct and now they're saying what a
day we want to hear how yours went text
us back with your favorite story
i was looking at the short text box
bring it up right here bring it up this
is the thread of texts
at no point have they told anyone
anyone who's signed up online
where or when it's happening
you can only know if you're
a part of some double secret probation
club i have no idea so again keep keep
this in mind when people talk about it
this entire thing is a sham
uh also really quick we're going to have
super mexican on
at the the the on the half hour there
and we're going to play spot the [ __ ]
bring that game back people like this
the spot
which brings me we want to talk about
the
the bathroom laws we have so much to get
to this week but uh of course the north
carolina mississippi brian adams bruce
springsteen
and ringo starr ringo starr have
cancelled their tours in north carolina
well yeah i think one of them one of
them was a different state one of them
was brian adams was mississippi
mississippi yeah for the same sort of
law right and the biggest losers of the
other 49 states where they weren't
cancelled yes exactly of course but not
egypt not egypt or or dubai places where
people like brian adams play frequently
where they can throw you off a roof for
frosted tips
so keep that in mind and i know it's
easiest low hanging fruit to point out
the hypocrisy i do want to we'll talk
more about springsteen and brian adams
and why they suck so badly the main
thing with bryan adams every time i hear
bryan adams song they're not bad songs
but i'm thinking oh
just that would be a lot better if it
weren't brian adams
he's the only artist where covers of his
songs are better than the original songs
you want to hear someone else do it
that's fair you would rather hear
journey doing
yeah a brian adam song most anything
really yes
uh so but the main thing we'll come back
to this the
issue they say well it's anti-gay the
only thing is transsexuals want to use
a bathroom without proving anything a
man with a penis puts on a dress thinks
he has the right to use a bathroom
that's all it is there is nothing else
there is nothing else this is a
protection where not only do they use
that bathroom but businesses have the
right to say no you use you use the
gender uh that uh that you are and
protects businesses of course from
things like the the business well we'll
get into that because there's so many
businesses and examples and people say
well why are you panicking it has
happened so that's the entire thing
penis men's room this is why people are
canceling their tours there is nothing
more to it they try and say it's
anti-gay and because they're trying to
feather in the at will state which means
i can fire not gay jared because i don't
like his face
the fact that he happens to be not gay
is incidental and it has nothing to do
with this law every state is an at-will
state and then they carve out exceptions
so i don't like my face so it'd be
completely reasonable it would be
entirely entirely it
so that's what they're trying to tack on
more it's not that's not what the bill
is about the at will state is separate
but i want to get to something that's
gone viral this week buzzfeed video was
questions for black people
so we're going to do this live right now
for those watching the live stream and
listening and then of course we'll be up
as a video but buzzfeed put out this
video questions for black people of
course entirely black people uh based of
course on stereotyping black people in
in pigeonholing them and then bitching
about how you're stereotyping and
pigeoning them pigeonholing them so yes
i know that i'm white
but i'm going to answer these questions
not as a black person
not as a white person not as someone
with a penis or lack thereof
but using logic let's go through the
video
if my dab is on fleek
did we just mess this up and hear it all
right are you cued up there not kj yep
all right let's go to the video why is
it a problem
uh let's see this is not going to work
it's not going to work this may not work
this may not work it wouldn't work
ah what happened was we had no time to
test this that's that's that's the
problem so it's not going to work the
clip may not work the clips may not work
okay does that mean no that means you
want me to move on yeah get back to me
okay get back to me
all right your punishment must be master
beer
but we will get back to that
so okay let me let me take that time
then uh with the trans sexual the [ __ ]
bathroom issue
that's as simple as it is it has nothing
to do with the at-will state
uh being fired at will gay people are
not being targeted and being fired now
why are states at will states
because they want to avoid the exact
kind of frivolous lawsuits that are now
occurring when men with penises try and
use the ladies restroom guess what
that's expensive
they're trying to avoid that
that's why it's an at-will state
two separate issues but they want to say
look they can fire gay people at will
they can fire black people well they can
fire white people well they can fire men
women they don't have to give you a
reason that's what at will means it has
nothing to do
with tally whackers in the ladies room
when it comes down to this issue of
course people talk about religious
protection remember remember when the
lgbtq aaip and asylum f they said listen
we don't care about your churches you do
your own thing we just want our own
civil rights well civil unions weren't
enough
gay marriage supreme court ruling it's
not enough
bathrooms not enough
gender-neutral bathrooms not enough
that's still hate speech just saying
listen we don't want to do the
complications so here men's room women's
room and let's create a gender neutral
bathroom that's not enough still hate
speech
saying okay you have the right to get
married you're recognizing the state
it's entirely the same as straight
marriage but if a bed and breakfast
doesn't want to host your wedding they
have the right that's not enough
listen yeah of course in the eyes of the
law you are totally married but we can't
force a bakery to be involved with your
wedding not enough
bakeries pizzerias bed and breakfast
landlords
all have either faced lawsuits or been
shut down
and they said it wasn't going to affect
any of you
they weren't going to come for the
churches well now guess what they're
protesting protection for churches and
businesses
that's their problem there there are so
many stops on this logic bus where you
could have gotten off and there could
have been some logical compromises
that's not what they want that's not
what the lgbtqai number two squared
wants
it will never be enough and once this
happens in the bathroom if there's a
supreme court
ruling denying basic biology
they'll move on to something else maybe
like salon.com with pedophilia and
people say you're no go to salon.com
they wrote several articles i'm a
pedophile but i'm not a monster no you
are a pedophile and you're a monster
this is mainstream leftism we're not
talking fringe sites okay this is where
we are
and one thing i do want to talk about
it's also it's not necessarily about
predators because you can't argue that
namely because we haven't studied hey
guys with dongs going into women's rooms
in the united states does that result in
more sexual assault we don't know
understanding the sexually predatorial
nature of men i would guess so
but let's not even argue that you don't
even need to the overwhelming majority
of women
are wildly uncomfortable
and feel very exposed
when people walking when men walking in
there use the restroom they're
incredibly an overwhelming amount of men
with daughters are wildly uncomfortable
with their daughters being in a restroom
with men
if you want to talk about rape culture
we don't even need to get to sexual
assault right if a guy looks at you
wrong
on
a campus at columbia it's rape culture
but
tossing a guy in the ladies room with
six-year-old girls no that's not a
problem what's wrong what's the matter
with you
what are you saying they're gonna do i
don't know i probably wouldn't be super
uncomfortable if some if some uh some
you know caitlyn jenner like sprite
waltz done into the men's room i
probably wouldn't care
but you know what
i think my wife would if someone like me
and a wig walked in
i think she'd be uncomfortable
to be very uncomfortable and i don't
think it'd be a safe atmosphere
i don't
why should we
completely just absolutely run roughshod
over the rights of
99.999 whatever percent of americans for
the rights of a very very small
percentage not the rights the wants
they're not rights they're not needs by
the way you don't have the right to use
whatever bathroom you're with it's not a
right
certainly not in a private business
i walk into if i walk into a stop by the
way subways never have bathrooms
they never have bathrooms you need the
employee key
the whole thing smells like a bathroom
the whole thing's about to stay and it
stays with you for like days oh my gosh
how far subway is falling
but
they're businesses all the time
no you can't use the bathroom unless you
buy something
they can't do that with bob who calls
himself bess
that's an aclu phone call waiting to
happen
you you sir you sir no bathroom no not a
paying customer no bathroom oh you you
hit the dick in your dress
come on right in come on right in
videotape i know it's illegal but make
sure everybody knows i'm tolerant right
they're doing with the dog and the dress
is coming in i let them in you serve not
so fast you have to buy energy drink
some tic tacs or something you you scare
your beautiful teleworker right on there
into the ladies room let everybody know
at this gas station we thought alright
the lgbtq aip do i have that right
i forgot an a oh i'm so sorry take for
free
don't call the aclu that's what's going
to happen
how many of you tweet me how many of you
out there at s crowder have been denied
using a bathroom in a private place
they've always had that right
now we've just tacked on absurdity this
is the lgbtq aaip bully pulpit it's not
even a majority of gay people there have
got to be tons of gay people out there
who are going they say anti-gay law has
nothing to do with me
okay don't lump me in with the highest
suicide rate in the industrialized world
higher than holocaust victims and
american slaves and schizophrenics
because they can't accept their basic
biology because i have a different
preference of friction it's not the same
thing
but they're piggybacking on it
not to create that visual but i just
created that visual we have to go pretty
soon we're going to take some calls
right yeah we have a bunch of calls this
week and uh okay your calls after the
break
get it right lgbtq aaip is the real
thing we're serious here stay tuned
okay business time really simple some of
you don't know where to find me
louderwithcrowder.com half a dozen to 10
articles every single day twitter follow
me at s crowder louder with crowder
podcast on itunes soundcloud or any
other podcasting device youtube.com
stevencrowder or you can type in steven
crowder on facebook and be one of the
million plus fans or join the mailing
list there are so many ways for you to
stay connected you have no excuse you
have no excuse just like you have no
excuse for those roles that are just
cascading over your belt buckle you
should be ashamed unless you're a lady
then you deserve get her a medal
[Music]
greetings humans this is a hopper
takeover the good news is i come in
peace
all you have to do is send hopper all
your sardines and cheeses
and no one will be harmed
you have until the next commercial break
to enter
[Music]
glad to be back uh
a good time in the studio live stream uh
today and
i usually don't like to do this because
i hate it when when hosts just pump the
phone lines and it can get kind of lazy
who wants to hear no but what what uh
johnny johnny from jacksonville from
jacksonville jacksonville nothing good
goes on down there nothing i don't we we
have actually a lot of listeners now
this is started off to a weird certain
anyway but today we do want to open the
phone lines and um
you know hear what's on your mind so
naked we have somebody on the line yes
uh yeah sam and i don't think he said
where he's from but okay so sam if
you're there online one you're getting a
lot of with crowder sir
hey uh stephen thanks for having me on
the show uh you know uh i appreciate you
opening the airwaves to the common folk
uh thank you i appreciate it um sam
what's on your mind today
well you know i wanted to see you know
your opinion on what you thought about
this donald trump winning all the
primaries
well that's kind of a loaded question he
hasn't won all the primaries and um he's
certainly not winning all the delegates
i get that the trump people are upset
about it but these are the rules and uh
he's been organized poorly so
i i guess i don't know what your what
your questions he hasn't won all the
primaries and there's a strong chance he
doesn't get the nomination that's what i
think well we'll see then see there's
you're clearly coming from a certain
place okay um okay what do you mean what
do you mean i'm coming from a certain
place well you clearly don't like the
guy okay now what i want to know is like
you know he's got that comb over you
know
and it and when it blows over in the
wind you know his head looks exactly
like a which is what you suck all day
long okay that's not that's not
necessary that's if you're going to
if we're going to keep you on the line
you're going to have to keep it so i
don't want nothing jared to have his his
work cut out from with the sensor button
okay
i'm just saying i think you would like
the guy since you like suck
okay come on come on seriously let's
let's
you got one last shot
do you have anything to say that's
productive to add to the conversation
we have other people on the line when
when we go to donnie in chicago
uh i think uh a couple segments coming
up okay
let's be calling in
um we did get some tweets people asking
me okay we wanted to they wanted us to
talk about the trump issue going on
right now this week with michelle fields
so
we're going to have ed morrison who's
more of a policy wonk listen we had ben
shapiro on i try to be fair in that
situation it really comes down to do you
believe that you should grab a reporter
or not doesn't look like lewandowski is
going to be charged
um so there we are
you know i
does that mean there's justice no
any of the many many dozens of people
who tried to file police reports at the
lansing right to work protest when their
tent was cut down and were told that
they were unable we'll tell you that
justice isn't always served
but
listen you have to be fair if you're
going to go that route with the law you
see the ride you bought the ticket and
there you are you can
that's those are the results so they're
not going to charge them they did say he
did grab her and uh it
i don't have the exact wording in front
of me didn't seem like it was too big of
a they didn't seem like they were too
fond of it but they said you know an
apology would have ended this whole
legal procedure imagine imagine that but
that's that's kind of a grown-up thing
right for the trump camp
so that's where we are with that i don't
really have any more opinions on that
she apparently michelle fields is filing
a perhaps a defamation suit and i know
they threatened said she doesn't want to
do that because they'll dig through her
past so
i don't know what am i going to
speculate about at this point if it were
me i wouldn't go with a defamation suit
at this point
i i would move on yeah i think it's i
think
there's only so much mud you could drag
people through and it doesn't really
benefit anybody i don't know like it
what do you get out of it right ruined
career for everybody well i think what
happened is it happened it was shocking
that's not the way you typically treat
reporters i think it's genuine the
reaction i don't think someone went in
there looking to get this people are
trying to destroy this woman's career
like i said with ben
listen either you think it's okay to
grab reporters or not
um as the level of which then p then
it's just a bunch of arguing over well
how severe was it it wasn't very severe
and as someone who has
been
violently assaulted uh as someone who
has family members who have been
very violently assaulted i i don't like
belittling it
but if that were my wife
and lewandowski and i were alone we have
some words yeah one thing it doesn't
change the fact listen okay you want me
to i can't speculate because the law
happened right you have to accept that
sometimes okay you may not like it but
you have to accept it i i hope i'm being
consistent here because i know the trump
people will will will uh either way no
no doubt be mad and hoping people on the
other side understand listen you fi you
tried to file the charges was justice
served maybe not but this is where we
are if they do a defamation suit we'll
keep you posted it doesn't change the
fact that corey lewandowski's a punk
doesn't change the fact that every
single time he grabs someone is when
they're looking away i think it's very
telling you know when that pro when the
protester at the rally right the guy's
looking at him
lewandowski had nothing to say nothing
to do and then he turns around and it's
a yanking of the caller yeah any guy
who's been in the arena any guy who's
wrestled in high school any any person
who's ever been a combat or physical
contact sport athlete
knows that's a guy who wants out knows
that's a guy who doesn't want to take
and same thing grabbing a girl when
always from behind always coming up from
behind that's my personal opinion but
you know i'm not a lawyer
okay
so uh i don't think we have a bunch to
talk about that here's something people
are talking about this we'll talk with
ed morrissey about this okay
ted cruz is doing really well with the
delegates right he's cleaning up
delegates um and trump is now
complaining i think it's just because he
understands how it works he understands
how it works
someone can correct me
and ed morrissey no doubt will he knows
this as well as anybody and that's why
we're having him on
the rules have been out there since
august and not a one has changed
none of them have changed
you may not like the rules
but these are the rules
something else people are saying oh it's
it's the pop it's not about the popular
vote it's not representative of the
popular vote well you know who benefits
the most from that right now donald
trump
i read this over here we have it from uh
from ricochet great site more wonky than
me but i read them every day um so so
far donald trump has drawn 37 of the
primary votes total
that's his ceiling
but he's won 45 of the delegates
so why are you complaining now like uh
for example he only won 45 percent of
florida gets away with all 99 delegates
so actually if you look proportionally
donald trump proportionally has far more
delegates than even the lead that he has
and of course we know now that that's
switched where he's behind ted cruz in
the national polls yep now i'm not
listen the system is the way i'm not
saying it's a flawless system but you
can't complain when it benefit when it
benefits the other guy and they remain
silent when it benefits you where was
trump when he was saying we shouldn't do
winner take all
he's still banking a winner take all in
new york the rules have not changed you
saw the ride you bought a ticket
what are we coming back with more calls
super mexican mexican coming up
[Music]
and now for donald trump plays family
board games brought to you by milton
bradley and al jazeera
okay your turn
uh case my turn
what are you doing
what are you doing here okay with baltic
avenue you're sitting at baltic avenue
with the hotel you're not doing anything
with it okay
i can do whatever i want okay it's not
true
that's not how the country works okay
you can't sit there and do nothing with
it there's got to be some kind of listen
this i'm going to i'm going to call my
lawyer i hope you your lawyer has a lot
of vowels in his last name okay and i'm
going to make sure that you don't ruin
baltic avenue used to be great okay
until you took it over okay used to be
fantastic frankly what i'll do with bolt
this whole game is rigged this whole
piece of
game is great
[Music]
stay tuned for more donald trump plays
family board games brought to you by
milton bradley and al jazeera
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar15.com oh there's another one
you got them thank god for ar15.com they
have ar15 and accessories for sale and
the best advice there is on the web oh
no there's another one
you got it yeah with your what ar 15
from where
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
[Music]
all right uh our next guest will remain
silent because we actually have intro
music for him i just realized i was
behind on twitter and so i had to let
everyone know that he was coming on yeah
he has a fan base it is
a guy um so uh as long as the board is
ready let's go to our super racist intro
because when you hear this
i am
[Music]
that means it's super mexican from the
rightscoop.com el super are you there
with us
well how are you doing i am doing well
okay well so people know that's not how
you speak
i know we'll work the first time but i
guess it's not gonna work again well we
don't want to risk it you know someone
out there who you know
we have people who dissect everything
and they'll be like they'll claim you're
like a joey tribbiany like that is the
worst mexican accent from a mexican ever
our fans are brutal
this is this is actually happening to me
right now this is amazing
you're gonna enjoy this is that uh this
is what i do whenever i call into a
radio show is that you know as a joke i
start off with this like really bad
mexican accent like how are you doing
and then the like you i don't tell the
host that i'm doing this so they freak
out they're like oh my god is that how i
was actually gonna talk
and then you know us ten seconds later
i'm like i'm just kidding this you know
that's not what i sound like well anyway
that means they're racist
this is true i do this for my podcast
ideas for everything right and uh and
there's these people out there
who think that
they don't understand that it's a joke
and so
they think that i'm a fake mexican
because
you know i have a i use a fake accent at
first and then i talk in my regular
voice but what is your background
incredible uh but well i was born in
california uh which is the uh which is
the northernmost point of mexico right
and um
both of my parents are are from mexico
okay
i was born here so yeah you know i'm i'm
you know i'm american but i'm from uh of
of mexican descent are your parents
short
i am taller than both of my parents
i knew it
so yeah yeah i was i felt that was safe
with those vegas betting odds yeah yeah
we're good bro right there
from mexico
so i i really apologize but i apparently
i don't have enough melanin in my voice
like i need to work on that so i you
know i'll try to yeah you do need to
work on it and listen i mean
i i don't want to to mexican shame you
but you know i i'd feel satisfied if you
mexican shamed yourself you've had a
busy week
so
roger stone for those who don't know
former trump act active what do you call
him former trump operative he doesn't
work with him anymore i think he was the
campaign manager
or advisor or strategy what was the
official title do you know well he was
like his aide he's a long time friend
he's known him for many many years and
uh and right right when he
uh when trump began his presidential
campaign he was fired all of a sudden
and ever since then he's become this
trump operative
and you know they have the they have the
ability to to say well he's not a part
of the campaign but everything anytime
something really
shady happens around trump roger stone
is there so yeah well i wanted to talk
about that because the rightscoop.com uh
is is not a pro trump site you're one of
the few and you know the problem is
we've invited plenty of people on from
and they just won't do it they won't
argue on the show publicly many people
out there surrogates have all been
invited don't want to do it people who
are big advocates some of them who are
friends of mine they said well this is a
behind the scenes thing um so it's hard
it's not like i mean listen we've had
we've had communists on and terrorists
who want me dead
so if if people out there who are
legitimate sites now if you have 100
followers want to make the case you're
more than welcome to um but roger stone
was saying he was going to post
addresses and a lot of people thought
that was in poor taste and you were
calling him out a lot and then he he
directly tweeted you right
yeah it was a very nondescript thing you
know i don't want to make a big deal
about it but it is kind of weird because
uh what he tweeted is basically we've
been going after him because
at least to us it's the most obvious
thing in the world right you fire this
guy he actually ran the dirty tricks um
political wing of nixon's campaign way
back in the day so
all of a sudden you know he's calling
for
riots and protests he's giving out
addresses of people's names who are
delegates who are anti-trump delegates
and so this is the clearest thing in the
world to us i don't know why other
people aren't covering people mad at us
and they said well you didn't talk about
later in the interview where he said
peaceful he said it's like okay he said
day of rage and he was going to post
addresses
listen i don't like uh bernie sanders
okay i'm never going to post bernie's
address or people who support him and
say let's start a day of rage i would
hope that we could both agree on that
soon
you can peacefully rage apparently you
can peacefully rage peacefully you're
just like rage doesn't mean what you
thought i'm
kind of angry
rage means peace penis means vagina
sorry l super there you go um
so have you had anything behind the
scenes as well or just or no
not
yet
yeah but he so what he did
is he sent this little tweet and and we
really go hard on him because he really
does seem like kind of a scummy guy and
so you know i rail on him i just say
this is uh trump's lackey and he's kind
of a scumbag and and so i it was one of
the headlines and he responded he just
says you know i love you too i thought
that's really odd and and to me how did
you directly at replied him or was he
just uh uh the subject of the article i
think he was yeah he was monitoring you
know articles about him and uh so i i
think you know it was kind of a heads up
like hey you know we're watching you uh
right which is not something you want to
hear from
a psycho like him who has billionaire
backing you know well no no no don't you
he stands up against the billionaires
this is true he stands up against the
establishment by posting addresses to
people who were elected by their
neighbors uh on a day of rage a peaceful
day of rage all super
exactly right well that's because you
know uh we're taking away their vote so
that that's why we deserve to be hunted
down with uh pitchforks and torches but
no it's it's completely absurd and the
sea this is the thing that kills me is
is and i'm sure you get the same thing
is that
all of these troglodytes like these
illiterate morons like we said last time
we were talking about that's not all of
them
what this is your problem it's an
insensitive [ __ ] continue
you know they're not there's some decent
trump people that's fine but the the
loudest ones are are real you know
creatures and they come after me and i'm
sure you've gotten this too
where they say that i'm an establishment
chill and that the gop
you know conjured me up and that i've uh
i'm a product of the establishment and
i'm like they're that's insane like i've
been speaking about out against the
establishment for years now but all of a
sudden if you're not on the trump train
you are the answer well donald trump
wants it both ways and he says no well
nobody likes frankly nobody likes ted
cruz okay these politicians like him
they like me and then he says he's the
one who's going to fight the politicians
and there's no track record of it yeah
you know and that's one thing that
bothers me i like him but a lot of these
a lot of these hosts listen i'll say it
you know mark levine you guys of support
has been really good about this and you
can hear the frustration in his voice
but rush limbaugh and sean hannity and
some of these people on fox news when
they set it up as though trump but the
establishment they never say trump and
you know what and and strong tea party
conservatives who don't like him
it's it's a sleight of hand and i know
that they know better so for some of
these big names to simply paint it as
though trump and establishment
i don't know about you but that seems to
me like someone who's hanging on to a
listenership in a dying medium and not
being entirely forthright am i out of
line
i think uh i think that's true i mean i
think that's kind of what trump
represents you know um it's really weird
because trump represents so much
of the criticisms that liberals have
been making against conservatives and he
just fulfills them you know what i mean
so his
supporters are you know they're older
they're uh they actually don't care
about conservative principles they're
very pragmatic
um they they just you know i don't think
they're pragmatic i think they're
selfish i don't think that the wall idea
and making mexico pay i understand where
you're coming from but i think that
gives a lot of these people too much
credit you know i don't think it's
pragmatic when there's no actual like
economic solution it's just yeah i want
no free trade how he's gonna negotiate a
good deal oh sure i don't know but you
know but i understand what you were
saying yeah it's a it's a yeah no you're
right that's not exactly the word for it
it's it's uh yeah we have the strain in
america that and and a lot of people
talked about is that we just want
problem solved we're very impatient like
if there's a problem just solve it and i
think you know proper
rational philosophical conservatism says
hey sometimes there are just problems
that we need to wrestle with and they're
not specifically solvable in fact you
know one of my heroes is thomas soule
i think one of the
the epitome of conservative thought is
this quote from him which i think is
utterly brilliant brilliant and he says
there are no solutions there are only
trade-offs i like i'm not even joking
i'm like chris matthews when i say it
i'd like get tingly about it because i
think
that sums up conservative thought like
if if somebody is selling you a solution
like we should just do exactly it's
going to solve something it's like
you're full of it any
every time that you have power and it's
collected at the top and they're going
to make a a huge decision decision
there's going to be people who
are negatively affected by it and
there's going to be people who are
positively affected by it if somebody is
telling you from the left or the right
that they have this absolute solution
that's going to fix everything they're
usually like well that's antithetical to
everything people railed against with
obama right like if people say the
number one well it's immigration i'm a
single issue voter you know if you're
going to be a single issue voter it
should be about the disproportionate
amount of power in the last eight years
you could argue in the last 16 years
george bush did it too that has been
given to the executive office school
house rock three branches of government
we're not in balance anymore if you want
to talk about the key issue that's the
key issue right and so you want the guy
who doesn't really want the job
sometimes you want the guy over they go
hey i'm poor hey i lost my job and he
goes yeah yeah you know that sucks can't
help you
sometimes that's what's what's needed
that's exactly right yeah
um and there's too many people who you
know what i i i was really shocked by
this i mean i thought that we were the
rational party that they kind of
understood that not everything has a
solution and
you can make things better or you can
make things worse but you can't
positively completely solve everything
and trump comes on on the scene and is
like i am going to wave my you know
magic wand and i'm going to fix
everything and these people are falling
for it and you look at them and you're
like wow like you sound like a democrat
that's what democrats do they
think that you can solve that you can
wave this magic big government wand and
solve everything and that's that's just
that's not us but have you noticed
something because you started off and we
were kind of in the same boat where we
always made fun of trump because he's
comedy gold but we were like listen i
understand the value in sort of
shattering political correctness oh yeah
we were on the same page there let's see
what happens and then we realized he was
never going to espouse things that we
believed in okay well here we are and
there was a transition and have you
noticed this i have no problem with
people like you said you say listen i
don't care about any of those things
anymore i just want a wall or you know
what i just want to do with free trade
i'm fine with those people you have
those people and then you have some
people who had to do a lot of mental
gymnastics sort of the christian tea
party conservatives and or even just con
the ron paul sort of libertarian
conservatives and i feel like you're
seeing some of those people now go oh
okay this isn't what i thought have you
noticed that
a little bit yeah i think you know even
early on ron paul himself
said that he wasn't gonna endorse
anybody because nobody was a was really
espousing the views of libertarianism
and i think i'm seeing a little more of
those people come around because they're
with i am you know i don't throw myself
in with that crowd uh completely but i
do agree with them on a lot of things at
least their principle they have they
they're very principled about these
things and probably
you know to to an extreme like that's
the fault is that they're overly
principled on a few things and they want
to jettison everything else out having
to do with social conservatives and
things like that but in any case
they are actually very principled and i
think what they're seeing is that you
know this guy is is is
is uh the the like you said the
antithesis of what they i think they
first thought we have to go to a break
soon i think we can talk about it we'll
come back you're playing spot the [ __ ]
right
oh yeah absolutely okay great yeah you
know we'll all lose our jobs um i think
they thought hey libertarians they were
pulled between uh destroying the
two-party system but then they realized
this could be actually worse than the
rhinos so i understand they were tired
of republicans like we all were and then
there was another fork where okay
ted cruz and donald trump are not the
typical republicans and now there's
another choice all right
super mexican we'll come back your
favorite game spot the [ __ ] yes tons
of hate speech ahead stay tuned
[Music]
this week in cultural appropriation
[Music]
well mr sakuraba your application here
at the university of michigan is nothing
short of impressive
thank you very much i tried to bring you
my family a great honor well you've
certainly done that oh thank you thank
you your sats are incredible uh your
extracurriculars are through the roof
your grades are as good as they can be i
look for many sons uh-huh yeah
unfortunately
we do have a slight problem
are we clear you know the truth is your
situation just isn't that all uncommon
and well we gotta figure out honestly we
have too many asians with the fight i
don't understand
i
[Applause]
we have to respect his culture
join us next week for more in cultural
it's not a appropriation we will party
hard
[Music]
all right we are back
with
super mexican at super mexican spelled
with two o's are you with us sir
yes okay you are with us and uh
have you ever seen this game before
are you aware of the rules
i don't think i have okay so let me set
it up for you we've played it with
we played it a few times played it last
time most recently with gavin mcginnis
so
i have said that i have a [ __ ] dar and
have not been fooled yet that is very
easy to determine this is my argument
and so not gay jared my producer
sets up pictures and we we play you and
i can compete here to see and i'm the
reigning champion
we're going to see a picture and we're
going to you simple is it is it a a
transgender or is that a real male or
woman and then we're going to tally up
the score any questions
all right i think i got it and you're
comfortable you're not it's okay we
don't expect you to be
i don't think you can be if you're
comfortable with this game there's
something wrong with you so well you
think you're on london with crowder
jared let's go too
and now live from transylvania
it's time to play
spot z
[Music]
we have high production values here l
super uh jared let's get the game
started we are going okay ready for
number one this is for you stephen
i'm gonna give you three seconds here
okay tell me
[ __ ] or not a trainee here we go
oh okay i am going to say
i'm not a [ __ ] with that i'm going to
say that's a woman do we ask supervisor
or just me it's just you it's just you
it's just me what do you think i think
that's a woman
oh okay wow i would have gone with that
too that's the first time ever which
will from the record first all right all
right and here we go for a super this
one's for you this one's for you all
right
there you go look at that one there
that's rough that's rough i think i
think that's uh actually steven crowder
so i'm to go with uh
i think i'm going to go with a guy
that's a guy
this is hate speed
we try to avoid that try to avoid that
you can't judge by
it's not fair
pardon my french
boom
what is it what is it that is that is a
that's a trans you think so yes do you
think so let's get the answer
you're right
all right okay
super back to you ready wow these are
rougher than i love they're not easy
all right here you go
cause i've seen some in my day oh
[Music]
be honest now nothing not nothing let's
not revert to the mexican accent we need
you to be honest because we have to
tally up the scores i'm very scared
right now i'm very scared right now
steve
uh
yeah i'm gonna go with uh [ __ ] on that
one
you're going to get soon
oh
and we're going to
yeah
super this is not good you're not
playing nicely on the program it's not
good it's not good all right steven last
one for you ready okay ready what's the
score super's up by one right by one but
he's got a lawsuit so yeah so
boom what do you think what do you think
oh come on no
no that's a woman that's got to be a
woman or am i
it's a travis granny no chance trading
model
my hot streak has come to an end
is your wiener confused
i don't is it thoroughly my whole body's
confused
that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying all right let's
go come on don't get me you're giving
all these easy ones
no no no no last one super ready here we
go boom
hmm
that's
what do you think what do you think
unfortunately i think i dated that thing
is this more acceptable in uh
mexico slash california i know maybe in
california i don't know about uh about
mexico i'm going to go with um not a guy
so
i'm going to call the aclu
you have gosh super travis oh
supercharged
super mexican okay what's the score so
super mexicans
he wins i was i'm surprised i mean he's
sued out of his mind i mean he's he's
got nothing here's the thing super if
you won but he took it you have to come
back to defend your title
so i don't know if you want this kind of
heat
uh
i see uh i say bring it okay
yeah i don't want a pcu
i want the whole thing he wants it all
right that was
live from
transylvania this has been
[Music]
uh
uh if you're comfortable with this game
you are not gay jared
yeah also they said that our mic was hot
during the last break and i should fire
you
but super mex super mexican seemed
relatively comfortable with it he didn't
seem uh too rattled
well if you're gonna fire him apparently
i'm gonna get sued into oblivion so i
might be looking for a job maybe i can
take that guy's job well i don't know if
you want that job because it comes with
i mean it already comes with the baggage
of several lawsuits with not jared oh
that's not going to work yeah namely for
me
he's this is 100 accurate yeah he's my
indenture yeah that's no bueno
at all so how do you see this happen
we're going to talk with ed morrissey
how do you see this happening do you
think trump gets the nomination you
think it goes to a contested convention
you know what the only way he doesn't
get the contested uh the only way he
doesn't get the nomination and we go to
a contested convention i think is if the
gop holds a line and they never hold the
line and they've already given signs
that you know they're a little spineless
on this uh if they actually cared about
the principles of conservatism i think
they would have gone after him a little
earlier and a little quicker and they
didn't so i could see
them caving you know even before the
convention uh the only way to save us is
if ted cruz gets a surge and we're not
looking we're not seeing that in the
polls yet i'm hoping for it i'm praying
for it i'm praying to all my aesthetic
gods but i
am not sure if that's gonna happen i
don't think prayers are very relevant to
them without human sacrifice that's why
all right
that's why your people haven't done
super well
it's in the fine print
ah i gotta read the fine bread man i saw
apocalypto i know what i'm talking about
what a great movie
really
i love that movie
never ended
all right
super mexican thank you so much for
being a good sport and you have to come
back to defend your title absolutely
you're going down thank you that is
super mexican you can read the stuff at
the right scoop.com highly recommend it
lighter with grouder stay tuned
[Music]
and now for donald trump plays family
board games brought to you by milton
bradley and al jazeera
okay right here how about a good uh
jingle
no okay frankly no jacob that look at
this piece i have okay it's it's it's
not even symmetrical
okay what is this what is a piece like
this it's not even a symmetrical piece
for jeggo okay of course the top you're
changing the rules you're changing the
pieces after we started the game okay i
wanted i want to look back at this and
find out which one of you is putting in
the eight symmetra i am gonna do okay
such brutal things to whoever is putting
asymmetrical pieces in jacob okay
okay i'm gonna do such you're never
gonna believe it whoever
[Music]
stay tuned for more donald trump plays
family board games brought to you by
milton bradley and al jazeera
greetings humans this
is another hopper takeover
um
your package seems to have been lost in
the mail
as i still do not have all the cheeses
but hopper is willing to overlook this
mistake and forgive provided they are
sent promptly to hopper's po box by the
next commercial break
i come in peace
but only if i has all the cheeses
otherwise i will be forced to roll on
the couch
the downstairs couch where i am not
allowed to go and i usually do not go
but you will force my hand in this
situation
i don't want to do it
all you have to do is send all
the cheeses
follow my instructions
and no couches will get dirty
[Music]
all right i am glad to we'll try the
phone calls one more time we're taking
your calls this week it's atypical we
don't do it a whole lot but not gay
jared has oh we've had this caller
before donnie from chicago correct yes
yeah daddy are you there
good donny good thank you how are you
sir
okay you're being far too kind so uh all
right what can we do
well here's the deal you know we got all
this we got all this nonsense going on
about everybody's already prophesying
about what's going to happen at the gop
convention i mean it's like already in
the books but here's the thing i got to
tell you
i got to tell you
i i know you're you're a listening type
of guy but you know if i were to go out
and say you know i want a new car i want
a new car
i would find one that i really really
like it's flashy it looks good and it's
people want it okay it's just a thought
for a minute because i'm going to try to
put all this together living in chicago
doesn't help because i see the disaster
the disaster of what the democrats have
done
to a city it's it's in the hole it's
like detroit it's tanking you got gun
laws that make absolutely no
has been democrats is it since 31 i
think mayor
uh
it's my father used to say hey every
city needs a good corrupt politician
like mayor daley the problem is is he
was right back then at least mayor daley
could say hey shut up we're doing it
this way but now everybody's corrupt so
you know you look at the dams everybody
knows what's so you know that what it's
done to people but here's the thing
i can't get it through my head
that the gop has given us anybody to
beat the nonsense of hillary or even
bernie look at the young generation they
love this guy i know they don't even
they love the guy because he speaks
about stuff listen i'm around
millennials all the time and i would not
put down a hard-working millennial a guy
with a 4.0 who's doing well in college
and all this kind of stuff but the fact
that they believe that there's a savior
out there that's going to change all
this is a disaster well i agree with you
and don't you see that kind of happening
right now with the gop that's what the
same messiah complex
well it is it is except this here's the
only thing okay the gop has never ever
given this the idea that listen we'll
just give you everything you want we
never did that the democrats have lived
off of hey you know let's give everybody
free everything okay they've lived off
of that look at what it's done to
detroit to chicago everything baltimore
but but
everything it's a disaster but but the
the the working with the language you
know people don't
so i have understand understand every
once in a while when i want to have an
intellectual conversation am i have to
change my language
what's happened is we the gop has not
figured out yet how to talk the language
of this generation that's and so that's
why i say
you know what are they one of the
how are we going to combat this and and
all i'm saying is every time i hear cruz
talk i just want to kill myself every
time i hear kasich talk i'm like are you
kidding me you've got great points but
the people that you're looking to
connect with they're not connecting guys
do you think trump is the better
communicator of them
well no here's here's what i'm saying
everyone he's dead last of anyone with
the millennials
but here's what's happened
here's what's happened for the gop
they're the ones that have said give us
a new car we want a new flashy car we
want something with power with pizzazz
with zesto that was my point right is
all these old cars are sitting in the
driveway and the gop instead of going
look we can't give these people these
cars why didn't they build somebody from
it within over the last four freaking
years
well why didn't they pick a guy with
with with sense that that that can
communicate and i can't listen to the
cruise i can't listen to cases i can't
do it well okay
donnie from chicago thank you for
calling in we appreciate it and uh i
think i think it's um i think it's a
valid question um i think someone argued
that was cruz listen to someone who
voted for cruz in texas
there's a bit there's a reason that
marco rubio lost florida big and ted
cruz won
texas big
two people
same job
came up the same way
anti-establishment tea party
one's voting constituency felt betrayed
and one said okay we got what we asked
for not everyone necessarily likes it
but that is a study in contrast yep um
and i do agree listen i mean if people
talk about this all the time you know
i'm talking like like a daddy from
chicago
looks like venice farina sticks with you
what people talk about this a lot people
you know you see all these conservative
provocateurs or these authors right now
who are kind of in their in their their
death throes
saying oh you know
mexicans blacks they talk about these
democrats these voters you know it's we
need white people there are people out
there right now saying it's about white
people we'll never win blacks will
everyone mexicans that's why democrats
want them any white people
you are looking at it the wrong way and
it's a democrat way of thinking if
republicans
just minimize their losses
in people under 35
to low double digits meaning if they
lost it i don't know 60 40.
as to the pose as opposed to the giant
margins by which they're losing them now
they never lose another election
it's a much bigger voting base under 35
you could even extend that number to
under 40
but certainly 35 and under i'm not just
talking 25 and under 35 and under okay
if you could change that voting base by
10 points just you could still lose it
by a big margin
just not as mammoth
republicans would never lose another
election
and that'd be in perpetuity because
you'd be building something
it's a future vote you're not just
talking about who's black today who's
white today who's mexican today okay
let's look at the demographic numbers
republicans have had a very very serious
problem there
and and that's reality
and no one wants to talk about it
something else we talk about
communication okay let's talk about
communication
we'll have we'll have um
morsi and morrison well do we have more
calls after we have one more call after
this i think we're gonna take one more
caller one two more
okay we're fine um
trump this thing right now is the new
york values thing people are getting mad
at ted cruz i got an email about that
today
that was a subject from a trump email
because i had signed up for
ted cruz hates new york values yeah yeah
here's the thing this is just such
populist pandering bull crap right any
conservative any moderate any non-far
leftist who lives in new york
would hear that and go
yeah unless you're one of those dummies
who thinks that because you're new york
you have to like the rangers or you're
from
you're from philadelphia like the
phillies if you're one of those stupid
people who ties your identity in some
city there's no helping you but you know
what any conservative who lives in new
york city goes hmm you know what yeah i
am a republican but i'm in a city where
i legally am not capable of owning a gun
to protect my family and my apartment
also landlords are being jailed if they
don't allow [ __ ] to use whatever
bathroom they want sorry being fined
also they wanted to ban big ups you know
what my city's values suck
put that on a grand scale nationalism
sometimes it sucks
i was born in detroit my dad was born
and raised in detroit i left when i was
younger
detroit values suck
anyone with common sense would look to
manhattan would look to de blasio
would look to bloomberg and say
yeah those values suck
why should that change
i don't understand i've never tweet me
it has credit i don't understand why
this should change well i live in texas
or i live in i live in utah and uh i
vote republican really what does that
mean well it means i believe in freedom
of speech i believe in the second
amendment i believe in federalism and
constitutional limitations to the
federal government and then that power
should be delegated to the states okay
hey yeah i'm from new york and i vote
republican well what does that mean it
means i believe in strict gun control
i'm against free speech higher taxes and
socialized programs and banning big
gulps how does that change based on your
geographical location unless you are
in the most technical
uh
matter of speaking a dumbass
unless you are an absolute [ __ ]
someone telling you if you think you're
a republican that your city's far far
far left policies do not represent the
mainstream values of republican voters
it should be a non-issue
it's only an issue for a stupid person
who goes new york values oh crap i'm
from there i'm from there hey insulted
the place i'm from
oh i'm not voting for that guy
oh so you like the gun control you like
the fact that uh the far left policies
you like the the stringent government
you like the high taxes no
so what's the problem i'm from there
i don't like how this feels
i'm uncomfortable i don't understand is
it just me not gay jared i
no you know i i i get it to a certain
extent because that's kind of cleveland
news i think it's these
northeast cities think more than most
kind of had that sort of like
we've been through hell and back at our
own doing
and we kind of band together kind of by
you know it's kind of a thing chicago
you just detroit because cleveland's now
cleveland
yeah it's probably not they've been
there and it's only going to get worse
in june july
um you know baltimore
new york city boston i don't know what
it is i think it's just the cold winter
is just kind of like
it's it kind of puts you in a group
think mentality of the city and you
can't
you know kind of get out of that you
know the sports that everything kind of
plays into it as well i think but
i don't know i don't i but that said if
someone were to say hey clinton sucks i
go huh
yeah yeah yeah it's bad yeah it's pretty
sucky you're not happy with the
political representation for sure of
cleveland no no i'm certainly not with
detroit no
we've gotten to kerfuffles with people
over there that's it let's just remember
cleveland is not to be mentioned in the
same sentence
as detroit cleveland looks at detroit
and they you are everything that's gone
wrong in this world yes you stuck
consumed no talent mediocre pieces
that's what cleveland says to detroit
cleveland looks at detroit and says
no talent
yes cleveland looks to detroit and says
i knew the grateful dead from 1966.
who the [ __ ] are you
we always get complaints about that but
if you have not seen that video
it is the best thing the internet has
ever produced
but i don't blame you
um i wouldn't want to be mentioned in
the same sentence as detroit i'm from
detroit there's a perfect example i can
say yeah detroit is is is way worse and
clearer it's so cold in the d yeah and
if donald trump said that i wouldn't get
mad at him i'd say well he got something
right we'll be back more calls after
this
[Music]
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
twitter at s crowder where i'm tweeting
all day long i'm ticking off the social
justice warriors you should see the
amount of hate i get on there far far
far worse than any fat sports
illustrated model or black lives matter
charlatan so listen it's free you get to
be entertained and you can chime in also
if you're following me on twitter you
can send me your tweets and maybe you'll
be lucky enough and i mean lucky enough
because i have a lot of followers okay
that they call me the follower machine
to have your tweet to me or not gay
jared included in our rockinest tweet of
the week so follow me on twitter at s
crowder if not
i don't want to say i have sights on
your mother but
oh she's dead
you're just saying that because i made a
mom joke no she's really dead well you
kind of walked into it
[Music]
and now for donald trump plays family
board games brought to you by milton
bradley and al jazeera
yahtzee [ __ ]
okay [ __ ]
[Music]
stay tuned for more donald trump plays
family board games brought to you by
milton bradley and al jazeera
[Music]
to you
all right glad to be back and uh for the
most part we've had a good time here
with the calls today and
let's go
to our line knock it here we have
somebody calling in yeah we have jack
from samson
jack from
simpson you're online one getting louder
with credit
hello steven how are you doing hey uh i
wanted to ask why you like putting so
many in your mouth okay jared
i tried to cut it out i don't think
we're going to do a whole lot more you
know we had
donnie from chicago um
all right you know by the way one thing
for people when you talk about sort of
to put in some context here um my uncle
my brother have gone in and taped a lot
in india just want to bring this up real
quick and they've worked with some
missionaries uh just last night they
burned down 20 churches
um more than 200 churches in the old
sabang province and um
i have right here they want to kill
200 missionaries within the next 24
hours
yes islam so christians are hiding in
villages this is happening in india
right now so that's when people say well
how do you say this many more people are
killed uh by islamic terrorism than uh
than uh timothy mcveigh well they want
to put out 200 just in this province of
india in one night for being christian
this stuff happens all the time across
the world so all the time every anytime
you can snap your your fingers
someone's being killed in the name of
islam somewhere in the world not by a
muslim
that's the sound of somebody being
killed in the name of
islam with that amount of frequency
every single day
keep that in mind the next time they're
hunting for some kind of a a a a a white
uh anglo sex and ted cruz supporting
terrorists uh i wanted to talk about
something we were talking about uh pot
with julie borowski
borowski i don't know you know what
hopefully we'll do we'll do a web
extended version
i i think it's an entirely reasonable
intentable position listen states should
have the right to legalize if they want
to i just don't like it being based on a
lie
but i also find it funny why they've
made such a pivotal issue of weed
really an a non-beneficial drug um if
you want to get high fine that's but
let's let's not say it's medicine or for
mizzou companies they can make plenty of
money they have several patents on
chemical compounds from marijuana the
only one that works is is that uh the
the one that they have for
um
nausea in in sickness associated with
chemo
but no one's in the streets picketing
for that drug right it's not fun because
you're not getting high they're picking
on the streets because they want to get
blitzed that i understand it i just want
people to be honest about it
i don't understand the more compelling
conversation to me would be something
like steroids
and the reason i was thinking about that
i was just
arguing personal freedoms you're talking
about we're talking about personal
freedoms but i want to take it extended
yeah um because that is these are legal
drugs and they are drugs that are wildly
beneficial right a good ex steroids
right now they give to
you
no
um but they're wildly beneficial to aids
patients burn victims right that they're
prescribed they were invented they're
prescribed and there was a scare big
scare that happened after the the
russian and east germans with the
olympics right the steroid wars
and so now they're vilified but these
are legal drugs that have gone through
the scientific process and are some of
the most effective drugs known to man
and a lot of the time doctors would
probably prescribe these to people and
they're afraid because of the dea i
don't understand why libertarians don't
focus on that more that's where you can
make some headway the reason i was
thinking about it was because she talked
we talked about drugs with her i was
just reading today i follow mixed
martial arts there's a fighter named
leoto machida who just got fined for
testing for a ped
ped's performance dancing drug now
chelsea says every single drug
is a performance enhancing drug if your
doctor is giving you a drug that is not
performance enhancing that's malpractice
he cannot give you this makes sense a
performance hindering drug
the drug that was banned that this is a
private organization you uh usada their
guidelines are what i don't want to get
wonky for you was dhea
that's something you can probably many
of you watching might even be taking it
or it might be one of your supplements
and you don't even know certainly if you
have older parents or grandparents it's
most likely that some of them are you
can walk right now to rite aid to cvs
and take that
and it's banned in sport
and this guy's name is going to be
direct and by the way he didn't even
test positive he disclosed it he was
listening to supplements you know
whatever creatine this multivitamin dhea
and they said oh well
you're that's banned
so you're going to be suspended and i'm
sitting there thinking about this this
is an issue that again we've dealt with
in the media because of liars like lance
armstrong i understand it because of
people who abuse it
but you were talking about athletes and
i've given this a lot of thought
and i've gone back and forth on it
you're talking about athletes who
are putting their body under stress the
lifespan for nfl players is not good for
people who are in contact sports it's
not good we talk about concussions it's
really bad right cutting weight is very
difficult in these combat sports we know
the long-term health ramifications and
we know that steroids would help
we know that they would help these
athletes we want them to perform these
best and by the way if you think that
most athletes aren't on them you're
delusional okay most of these there's a
significant portion of them are ask any
professional athletes once they're
retired they go oh yeah it's absolutely
rampant
why shouldn't they have the right to
take those drugs you can tweet me at s
crowder i really think it's a hard case
to make that they shouldn't be taking it
under a doctor's supervision because
it's a witch hunt and new drugs are
developed
shouldn't athletes be allowed you can
give them percocet the addictive drugs
the painkillers are rampant rampant with
people in professional sports depression
rampant you can give them zoloft you can
give them all these antidepressants you
can toss oxyet them which we know is bad
it doesn't help you or you can give them
something that is possibly the most
effective drug known to man pick a list
from whatever these steroids are keep it
monitored within healthy levels from a
doctor and it will enhance this person's
performance who their sole job is
physically performing for you and we
tell them no here's a bottle of percocet
you can't take what would actually help
you heal
and so i was just sitting there i was
watching this going i was wrong with my
dad about i got getting tested for
something you know that you you take
it but it's not even that effective dhea
it's it's really mixed result creatine
is more effective creatine is a very
effective supplement that's one that i
recommend to a lot of people if you're
out there you don't know what it is
available
but
i don't i want you to tweet me as
crowder i'm just curious as to why the
line has been drawn at pot something
that's not proven
certainly not as time tested as as
steroids which can be prescribed by a
doctor and many doctors will tell you
you know what we prescribe these
specific kinds for these kinds of
injuries but we can't
and that's where i get more libertarian
again i've never touched these drugs
i've never smoked pot
but
i think if a doctor wants to prescribe
them they should i think doctors should
prescribe them uh
have the right to
if it works but we need to be honest
about whether it works and we'll be back
at morrissey right edward and morrissey
after the break stay tuned
[Music]
it only takes some time
[Music]
greetings humans this is the final
hopper takeover i have
cleaned my nether regions four times
since the last commercial break but
still have yet to see
any cheeses i would like to give humans
the benefit of the doubt and if
you believe that you should not send
jesus because harper does not have
opposable thumbs and would not be able
to open
the cheeses i can assure you i have
taken the proper precautions
and you can send them at your earliest
convenience
and lastly not get your escape
down how dare you i got up to dance
because i was tweeting out that ed
morrissey was going to be in the program
and you ruined the whole thing
tune it out my thing it's right now i
think i ruined it all tune it out now
okay don't let let's just pretend like
that didn't happen uh next guest fine
guest he hasn't been on a while but uh
longtime friend personally and he was on
the show when the first show started
long before syndication and then uh
several markets complained and pulled us
uh and then more syndication and then of
course more polling and then more
syndication ed
morrissey editor-in-chief at hotair.com
what's the official term ed senior
editor senior at hotair.com okay senior
editor and these these terms are so hard
to keep straight i know it's just it's
it's a nomenclature that kills you
stephen what can i say look at this
beard you warned me about it how long
has this been going on
uh about a month uh since cpac okay well
now because i saw you on morning joe and
i didn't want her how long has that been
happening because if it had been
happening for a year or something and i
had screwed up so what what was the
decision
well okay so this is kind of a funny
story what happened was right before
cpac i got a little rash on my lip right
up here and i thought initially well
i'll just shave around it right but that
would have left me with a mustache you
know right in there and i thought that
was a bad look at a conservative
political action conference so i thought
no i got to let the whole mustache grow
and then i thought well i'm gonna let
the whole mustache grow i need something
underneath it because you know with the
shaved head and just the mustache
yeah
don't i don't think that look what it
works
yeah pretty much you know so i i don't
know if this i don't know if this works
it does
it does work you have a decent period my
question is and then we have to get
because we only have one segment here my
question is this how do you you know
listen i don't think i'm letting the kid
out of the bag with the the healer
situation how do you decide where to
start the beard when there's no you know
usually you just continue the side burns
what's that decision process like
uh that decision process was like what
is it that i think i can actually
sustain and i i decided that this this
was it and i thought if it went all the
way up to the top of the ears it would
i don't know look weird not that this
doesn't but for some reason this is the
look that i kind of no it works it works
but you know because you don't want to
grow it and then you go full jesse
ventura with the skullet and that just
doesn't work for anything no that's bad
that's a bad look too okay so here we
are you have the new the new book title
of your new book it's going going red
right going red okay and you talk about
very you get very strategic in this
talking about the what votes determine
the republican election um real quick
just hit us with it because i know
you've been doing the press tour and
then i want to get into something
current to tie it into but
what's the premise the premise is is
that in order to win the swing states
the states that republicans used to win
uh before 2008 republicans need to get
back on the ground and discover who
these voters are the reason why
republicans have one of the reasons but
one of the big reasons why republicans
have lost in 2008 and 2012
is because they were relying on national
messaging they had no idea who the
voters were in these
in these swing states in these swing
counties seven swing counties and seven
swing states
and
the voters have changed their concerns
are different in each of these
communities you can't rely on just a
national message in the euro won a
national election anymore you really
have to run 435 congressional campaigns
for president and it's most critical in
states where voters are on the fence as
to which direction they're going to go
so that's what going red is about it
tells the stories of the seven counties
these seven communities so people get a
chance to know these people better
they're fine people terrific people i
got a chance to spend five months
touring and and talking with them no i
don't like them i think they're all
terrible people and i know endorser
coming okay but let me ask you this can
this be done ed without pandering was
still being absolutely no no see this is
the thing if you if you are talking with
the people in these communities you're
getting you're finding out what it is
that their concerns are in those
communities and then you take the
conservative agenda and show how it
applies to these to these issues to
these problems okay rather than just
saying liberty liberty free markets etc
you go into these different communities
and say hey you've got a problem with
the epa in the metropolitan water
district and it's going to cost you
hundreds of dollars a year for the next
20 years out of your pocket because the
epa
won't uh reconsider a plan to
for for abatement this is the reason why
regular
over
over regulation is bad not just saying
over regulation is bad you have to tie
it to people's lives and you have to
come up with a positive a positive
agenda that's going to improve like
kasich running a positive campaign let
me ask you point blank
no one no one i don't know maybe some
people like him when there are
occasionally there's a fan who pops up
with a yard sign which candidate do you
think is most capable of doing that
well look i mean i think um i think that
the candidates all have some qualities
that lend themselves to this i think
that they're one of the strong messages
that i got from talking with people is
that they're tired of ideological wars
they want somebody who's going to get
things accomplished that are actually
going to make a positive difference in
their lives
you know so that kind of leans against
ted cruz but on the other hand ted cruz
is really good at getting on the ground
and talking with people and and
presenting a conservative agenda in ways
that are specific to different
communities so he's good at that trump
is good at understanding that people are
frustrated and he's he's you know the
hyper competent super executive who can
get things done who is apart from the
ideological wars right and so that
appeals to that that's part of the uh
message too so you're telling me there's
a chance
chance
one segment so okay i understand where
you're coming from with that uh and
we'll have you back on when we can do a
longer segment we had to spot the tree
anyway and thank you so much for having
me on tonight i know that you squeezed
me in no no we didn't squeeze you and i
wanted to have you in and then it was
just the the schedule got insane with
the callers and not gay jared will be
fired um i wanted to ask you something
because you've written on politics for a
long time you particularly understand
the delegate game uh districts you
understand that better than most
what is the truth here have the rules
changed against donald trump have
they've you know
have they been the same i'm under the
impression am i wrong they were out
there in august and not a one has
changed since august
certainly not since august and most of
the most of the delegate allocation
rules are are really traditional you
know colorado changed up a little bit
over a year ago but
only just to say that we're not going to
have bound delegates the delegate
selection process is the same as it's
always been this is one of those sausage
making moments in in american politics
most of the time
conventions are over before they even
start their they're just there to
celebrate the nomination of the person
who we've known for months is going to
be the nominee this is the one year in a
generation the one cycle in a generation
where that's not the case and so now all
of a sudden everybody has to catch up
with these rules
and a lot of people are being taken by
surprise by these rules but they're
really the same rules that have been
around for decades in terms of delegate
allocation in terms of wooing delegates
this is the way conventions have always
been done
when there isn't a clear nominee by the
time the convention rules exactly and
that is designed to ensure that somebody
who cannot get a majority of even the
republican vote
doesn't go to a general correct right
right i mean that's that's that's the
overall purpose of it yeah absolutely
you have to demonstrate some confidence
you have to demonstrate a a broad reach
within the party that's right to
nominate you absolutely well that's my
that's why i talk about the two-party
system i said the two-party system is to
to avoid a national version of what's
happening with these primaries or
someone who can't get above that 35
threshold can take up the country
hostage and you've seen that in other
countries with with 30 or 40 parties and
i come from canada with a parliamentary
system so i go listen to party systems
isn't great
but it's better than most alternatives
and it's really easy to say you pretty
mean corporate influence but like look
at this look at this nomination process
in a primary do we really want this kind
of a quagmire in general
the difference between this system and a
parliamentary system is that we iron out
the the factional issues
prior to the general election within the
parties in a parliamentary system not
much candidate because there's really
only three parties in canada but
well there's there's liberal
conservative ndp and then in quebec
so poor parties uh
bq is more of a
quebec but they still run nationally
they are it's just so silly
but but you take a look at israel and
there's like what 12 13 different
parties in a two-party system those
those parties would kind of be divvied
up and they they'd vie for leadership
within the party before the general
election that's our two-party system
right so all we're doing is we're
replacing the stuff that would happen
in a parliament in the united states for
four years with
with this you know year-long process of
ironing it out in the in the in to when
we get to the convention that's that's
it's really this it's it's it's the same
type of function we just put it
ahead of the schedule more or less
than parliamentary systems and i can
understand people we've talked about
this i think it was obama obama hillary
clinton won texas obama got more
delegates i could be swapping them and
then mitt romney won some states but ron
paul got more delegates this is not new
like you said it's just it's more it's
coming down to the wires so for the
first time people are educating
themselves about it and i understand why
some people are angry i get it that with
the lindsey grahams mitch mcconnell's i
understand that i understand this
sentiment but the point is something is
not being stolen from someone if you
can't get over 35 or 37 percent of the
republican vote we're not this is people
are talking about this is talk posting
address tea party rioting the streets no
this is a party it's not the government
and this is one guy who doesn't even
have forty percent of the vote within
one half of the country's voting
electorate i just hope people keep it in
perspective before they go to cleveland
and start banging down hotel room doors
well i think so you know i i i actually
think that there's going to be a gap of
about six weeks between the final
primaries and the convention and i think
what you're going to find is
people are going to put the those five
or six weeks to pretty good use they're
gonna there's gonna be a lot of wheeling
and dealing to try to to try to nail
this down prior to the convention but
even if it goes to the convention and
you have a you you have 7 or 8 or 10 or
15 ballots before you get to a nominee
you know that's okay that's what
conventions actually are for they're the
backstop for when your primary process
doesn't pick a consensus nominee right
and that's that's what they're that's
that's why you elect delegates to go to
a convention so that you can so that
that can be done it's representative
democracy right it's it's it's it's it's
like congress well let's
let's write right let's follow down the
alternative right obviously trump
doesn't want one vote you know
representation he doesn't want that
because he's the one benefiting the most
from the delegate system and winner take
all states right there are no complaints
with florida and he's banking on new
york uh
far more a far higher percentage of
delegates than his actual percent of the
vote so people need to understand that
and my my thing is i've always tried to
be consistent consistency is what
bothers me but let's go down a lot of
trail the other way okay
just vote and that person wins is it a
good thing for someone who can't get
over that 36 percent threshold
to get the republican party is that is
that productive that that that's the
only sort of they would have to make
that a tenable position for people who
are yelling foul play right now or am i
incorrect no you're right about this and
and bear in mind that the primary
schedule was designed this time around
to prevent that type of thing from
happening as well the idea was to wrap
up a nominee early because remember the
the the primary kind of stretched out in
in the 2012 cycle too and mitt romney
ended up taking a lot of damage even
though it was clear that he was going to
be more or less the consensus nominee he
didn't get it wrapped up until later in
the primary and in the meantime he was
taking pot shots from fellow republicans
and then he had to spend all of his
all of his primary cash he had no uh
cash left and then the convention was in
the first week of september so he had no
way to answer these attack ads that were
coming from you know just go to all of
his secret mormon gold we know they have
those hordes laying around he doesn't
pay any taxes ed ed you're slipping on
the fact game here you need to
what can i say what can i say i forgot
about the mormon goals you forgot about
the mormon gold i forgot about that oh
my gosh how could i forget about that
that's what's really destroying the
party is the mormon gold that's that's
the real problem
but you're right i mean so
they front loaded the primaries this
time so they didn't have to go through
that but but the problem was that they
had a number of candidates who had
viability and and so what you've got is
this four or five six candidates that
were buying from vying for real votes in
the first part of that front loaded
primary and so now what you've got is
the extent what's left over and it's
going to stretch all the way to the
convention now because they did there
well that was going to be my final
question we have to hit a hard break you
think we're going to a contested
convention i think it's pretty likely at
this point i mean i think trump could
still get to 12 37 but i think we're
going to go to a second ballot or a
third ballot in cleveland yeah that's
what i'm kind of expecting okay
going red going red he doesn't he spells
it properly ed morrissey we'll get you
back on and uh i don't we'll play one of
the games with you maybe you and
supermax can ed thanks so
much we have to go sir love the beard
louder with crowder
stay tuned we're gonna wrap this all up
in a nice
bow because we can't wrap it up in a
beard that's physically impossible stay
tuned
[Music]
and now for donald trump plays family
board games brought to you by milton
bradley and al jazeera okay uh right
foot on red okay right foot uh
oh oh
no okay you know what this game is
rigged and don't think i don't know
about your little secret okay that you
are playing a game you've stacked the
deck okay you shrieked you're a
professional gymnast don't think i
didn't do my research i have people okay
who do the best research the best i did
tumbling class when i was five she's the
doubler class where she was like and you
didn't disclose it huh
disclose any papers any of your forms
you didn't disclose it
and you do okay lie lion lion michelle
okay that's your lion michelle we were
just playing twister you're not like oh
she's not alive okay look at this look
look at
you stretched armstrong going to the
ladies room huh huh this whole game's
rigged
[Music]
stay tuned for more donald trump plays
family board games brought to you by
milton bradley and al jazeera
[Music]
[Music]
so
hmm
i don't know what you put in this drink
that drink only the special it's nice
hold on one second
oh my lord that was cold
i haven't isolated that
and it seems to have gotten colder and
now my mouth hurts
you're welcome so that was at morrissey
you had ed morrissey uh going red is his
book i highly recommend it i know you
know listen we go from playing spot the
[ __ ] to thoughtful political
discussion but ed morrissey knows that
pretty well and he's a kind man he's a
nice man uh usually we don't present
other stories in the final segment but i
thought this was pretty important we
just wrote about it tonight at
louderwithcrowder.com
by the way the buzzfeed segment that not
gay jared for which she will be fired we
couldn't get working that'll be up on
the website uh probably tomorrow
buzzfeed released released a wildly
racist video stereotyping black people
were going to just answer their 27
questions that they thought were cute
and show you why it's pure dancery
here's the other story bill nye
uh video we have it up the website
thinks and he made the statement
that
all not global warming climate change
skeptics
should be imprisoned
i'm not going to play this right now you
can go on the website his reason and he
said for me as a taxpayer and a voter
the introduction of this extreme doubt
about climate change is affecting my
quality of life as a public citizen
i'm glad he said public citizen and not
scientist
at least he dropped that moniker
so
this is what we call the everything goes
under the general welfare clause right
at 5 or 15. well where's that in the
constitution general welfare clause
um i want free health care
how is that concern ah
general welfare clause
i want free food what does that go yeah
general welfare clause
i want to use any bathroom i have a
general welfare clause i want to make
sure that businesses have to serve me no
matter what at any point they have no
right to say sorry
general welfare clause who's jennifer
welfare did i say jennifer
general welfare general welfare i'm
going to write that down
that's right he can be taught
sometimes and now we go further on down
the trail and you have bill
nye
i want to jail all people who dis i want
to as noted non-scientist bill nye
jail that includes 30 000 real
scientists who actually signed a
petition against climate change let
alone the millions of people who aren't
convinced of man-made
global warming climate change
now to be soon to be global cooling
again after the last few years
he thinks that all of these actual
scientists should be jailed
well how's that constitutional yeah
general welfare clause
and they toss everything underneath it
they want to jail you
for having a different opinion
and scientists
he's not a scientist he's certainly not
an atmospheric scientist you know he's a
scientist
coach mark crypto
degree in geology
a lot of scientists
they like fracking
when you actually get down to science it
is way more split
and
this goes back to
why why jail them why not argue about
ideas well it's affecting my personal
life as a citizen
the
ban farts
if you're at that point there is a
movement i can get on board with well
i can't because hopper would be hauled
out here in cuffs he'd be the first to
go that's true that's true but my point
is you can't just sandwich everything in
there and the left uses it to silence
all
voices of opposition
fight for 15 there was no transparency
no one was notified of where it was you
signed up for the email it was
impossible why because they don't want
the cameras rolling they don't want
reporters to show up who might challenge
their beliefs
college campuses
they're going to ban you we wrote about
that on the website this week they're
going to ban you if you offend people if
you trigger people on campus right
conservatives are saying hey you can say
whatever you want sure you want to do
the piss christ art thing go ahead bring
that on campus you want to do all kinds
of anti-christian anti-conservative you
want to step on the american flag
absolutely go ahead conservatives say
that if you're the conservative group's
on campus anyway
left to say no no no we need them banned
kick them out segregated spaces
they don't want transparency they don't
want that dialogue bill nye
non-scientist wants
actual scientists
jailed
doesn't want a dialogue
there is a consistent
requiring of a lack of transparency on
the left that you should find is
concerning and you should find equally
disconcerting any time it happens on the
right
and i'll give this to libertarians they
really do focus on transparency we were
talking about a guy like justin amash
who i don't agree with him on everything
justifies every single vote he makes on
his website social media page
that sounds great
listen we're not mob rule we are not
total democracy but in a representative
republic
isn't it great to have one who's
transparent whether you like them or not
this is a trademark of the left
and this is listen people will say well
okay you know obviously sometimes we're
making arguments on lottery with crowder
and we're drawing parallels bernie
sanders fascism for mediocrity because
he wants to socially engineer
right classes and capitalism and free
enterprise we talk about his classes are
moving
bernie sanders wants to ensure that
doesn't happen that's
fascism for mediocrity okay we're using
that as an analogy
this is actual fascism how can you argue
how can the left argue that this is not
very blatant literal fascism jail people
with whom i disagree
and why isn't this front page
everywhere you know you have people
getting mad they're saying you know that
ted cruz wants to establish a religious
oligarchy because he's a christian we've
had atheism mark riptoe is an atheist
was on the show he said no actually if
you look he doesn't want to do that at
all he believes in those powers of the
state just like rand paul deeply
catholic he does not want to establish a
religious oligarchy
what about a guy like bill nye
and his views are mainstream leftism who
wants to jail people for disagreeing
with sketchy science by the way
climate change settled science gender is
fluid if you say you were born with a
penis of vagina that's hate speech
that should be so alarming to you to
americans i hate to do i'm not doing a
doomsday thing read the article look at
the patterns
we need more dialogue we need more
conversation we need more battles of
ideas the left has disdain for it
know that
and know who's looking out for you
that's us lottery with crowder see you
next week
[Music]